[Musique]
non
bonjour à tous bienvenue à cette
première émission de notre couverture
spéciale sur la visite du pape françois
au canada qui le mènera d'ici vendredi
soir denton à québec puis à iqaluit dans
le nunavut vendredi il est attendu en
alberta dans moins d'une heure nous y
serons bien sûr
c'est un moment historique
vous savez il vient à la demande des
communautés autochtones leur présenter
des excuses officielles
ici chez eux pour la maltraitance
infligée à leurs enfants dans les
pensionnats gérées par l'église
catholique une maltraitance qualifié de
génocide culturel dès 2015 par la
commission vérité et réconciliation
alors pour bien des autochtones métis et
inuits ces excuses sont une étape
incontournable sur le long et douloureux
parcours de la guérison et de la
réconciliation dans lequel nous avons
tous d'ailleurs un rôle à jouer mais il
nous ferons de notre mieux pour y
contribuer au cours de cette couverture
spéciale heures avec moi tout au long de
ces émissions de très très précieux
collaborateurs l'ethnologue
anthropologue et chargé de cours à
l'uqam isabelle by picarel et de la
nation wendat oui madame picard oui
bonjour et notre collègue bien sûr
journaliste et ancien animateur de
second regard où il a couvert
l'actualité religieuse spirituelle et
poursuit je dirais sa quête à laives
alain crevet sa quête et ses
interrogations sur audio à travers des
balades au entre autres de la série être
bon joueur quand vous savez que jamais
j'aurais passé de 6% non c'est vrai vous
avez vous auriez pensé que le pape
viendrait finalement
celui qui était premier à dire ça ne
fonctionnant pas votre affaire sanaa on
n'exige pas d'un chef d'état de venir
s'excuser en terre étrangère alors
justement j'avais vous demandez est ce
que vous diriez que c'est la découverte
il ya un an à l'été 21 deux cent quinze
tombes anonymes et
près du site du pensionnat de kamloops
qui force est en quelque sorte la main
l'église ça a été et invariablement je
pense qu'on doit dire cet indice largeur
un très gros déclencheur persécutés dans
toute cette histoire qu'on parle c'est
pas nouveau je ne dis pas c'était une
tragédie qui s'était produite il ya 10
ans 15 ans a fait clairement au 19e
siècle et ça s'est poursuivi pendant
santa et il a fallu attendre quand même
des années 80 pour que les premières
communautés religieuses impliqué
commence à dire on s'excuse on n'aurait
pas dû qu'à placer des églises comme
l'église anglicane presbytérienne 10 on
a fait une erreur la majeure il a fallu
attendre tout ce talent et quand est ce
qu en fait est arrivé l'école la
conférence des évêques catholiques du
canada quand est ce qu'ils se sont
excusés après can't lose après ma rivale
donc en 2021 quand je dis tout
simplement qu'il ya quelque chose là
dedans qui est explosif c'est ça c'est
certain ça me touche et la fibre la plus
humaine que nous avons tous et sa tête
ébranlé les institutions isabelle donc à
l'indien faire l'exposé et d'autres
églises
impliqué dans la gestion des pensionnats
se sont excusés depuis longtemps
l'église catholique a tardé tarder
tarder en dépit des demandes répétées
peut-être rappeler aussi que le but
c'est passionnant c'était de deux tués
l'indien dans l'indien c'était solide
pour ça qu'on a parlé de génocide
culturel oui absolument donc le but
c'était de tuer l'enfant finalement au
coeur de l'indien on le gouvernement
fédéral avait essayé toutes sortes de
différentes façons de contrôler si vous
voulez le fait est bien de régler ce
qu'on appelait à l'époque le problème
indien en passant par la loi sur les
indiens et autres la mise en réserve ça
fonctionnait plus ou moins et donc on
s'est rendu compte évidemment que si on
prenait les enfants en bas âge et qu'on
lit mal et qu'on les assimile est à une
religion autre à une culture autre à une
langue autre on avait plus de chances de
réussir donc dès 1831 le premier
pensionnats pour autochtones à brantford
en ontario a vu le jour donc ça fait
quand même très longtemps auprès de 200
ans alors on voyait revenir on aura
toutes sortes de témoignages pour nous
raconter comment ça s'est passé
cccc enlèvement d'enfant parce que
plusieurs d'entre vous l'entendrez au
cours de l'émission ont été arrachés à
leur famille à leurs communautés parfois
c'était des villages entiers d'ailleurs
qui était privé de ses enfants de cette
façon là alors le pape ont aussi a
fourni des excuses en avril je me
retourne vers vous à nouveau à l'alpa
peuvent fournir des excuses en avait
déjà une délégation autochtone s'était
rendu au vatican mais ça c'était que la
moitié du pas qu'il avait à franchir
parce qu'il fallait qu'ils viennent ici
parlez-nous ses excuses en avril est ce
que elle répondait aux attentes de la
commission vérité réconciliation par
exemple c'est quand on a d'abord ça
devait avoir lieu à noël puis après sa
mort d'amy et tout le reste je masse a
été reportée fin mars les excuses aviary
le 1er avril dans la salle climatisée
n'ont ni d'adam très institutionnel mais
quand j'ai vu ces images là j'ai pas pu
faire autrement que de penser à phil
fontaine ancien chef autochtone et je me
disais comme une fois y est allé au
vatican cogné à la porte du pape aux dix
premiers vous excuser il ya un moment
donné où ça
comme soyez intacte nous pas là ça
aucune importance il ya quelque chose là
dedans qui est de lob de l'acharnement
de vouloir obtenir justice mais de la
commande et ça finit par être très très
choquant alors il ya donc là dans la
salle clémentine le 1er avril après des
rencontres qui ont eu lieu avec le pape
il ya la ushl a déjà il y en a même qui
est antichoc il y en a qui est en habit
traditionnel on joue du tambour on
chante on joue du violon devant le pape
dans cet endroit qui est tu peux pas
voir plus si chanel que sony et le pape
prononce ses excuses qui pour moi même
aurait laissé sur mon appétit il dit en
somme il ya des gens qui se sont mal
comportés non il n'y a pas dit nous nous
questionnons on le savait on savait tout
seul on ne rien existe avez-vous coin on
avait dit il ya pas dix ans mais
curieusement ce sont des autres attaques
m'ont dit ça après peut-être que les
gens qui étaient là étaient satisfaits
et étonné que le pape se rend jusque là
là ce sont peut-être des excuses
incomplète on verra fois et dans le dos
qui seront contents parce que il a il a
dit quelque chose il a pris certains de
ses chefs autochtones dans ses bras il
les a regardés dans les yeux oui c'est
un moment c'est un moment important ne
sais pas
si on va y revenir parce qu'on dit que
on peut se rendre à l'aéroport de luton
où se trouve notre collègue widi ned
paul et où évidemment on attend
l'atterrissage de l'avion je pense pas
qu'on le voit encore moulinette parlez
nous de cette délégation parce qu'elle
est imposante à la fois ceux qui
attendent l'arrivée du pape et ceux qui
vont aussi arrivé avec le papa en parlez
nous de celle de ceux qui attendent
ouais exactement par d'une délégation
des dignitaires qui ont été bien sûr
sélectionnés par l'équipe ici
aujourd'hui geneviève à edmonton on
parle quand même d'une vingtaine de
dignitaires là qui vont pouvoir
rencontrer le pape à l'aéroport je
reviens sur cette cérémonie d'accueil
officielle qui sera très courte je vous
le dis d'emblée ce sera une brève
cérémonie environ 15 minutes et joue
amène à comment ça va se passer alors on
parle de l'aéroport de vancouver
edmonton et c'est ici que l'avion du
pape va atterrir vers
11h20
les premières personnes qui vont sortir
de l'appareil c'est une délégation du
vatican on parle ici entre autres de
membres des médias mais aussi du
personnel de sécurité du pape une fois
cela effectué on va avoir une plateforme
élévatrice qui va se placer vers
l'arrière de l'appareil pour que le pape
qui se déplace en fauteuil roulant
puisse descendre de l'avion il va
ensuite se rendre juste devant cette
partie de l'aéroport c'est à dire en
garde et c'est à ce moment qu'on va voir
le premier ministre justin trudeau
accompagné de la gouverneure générale
venir accueillir pour la première fois
le pape françois en sol canadien et je
vous amène à fait trois sièges que vous
voyez à derrière cette salle le pape va
s'installer au milieu à gauche il y aura
le premier ministre trudeau et à droite
la gouverneure générale vous car mais je
me permets aussi vous dire que le
premier ministre hugo on a vu son avion
qui est déjà ici à l'aéroport pour vous
dire à quel point on se rapproche de ce
moment quand attendu une fois installé
il y aura un salut militaire et ensuite
il y aura un premier chant accompagné de
cambourg un chant officiel d'honneur
pour souhaiter la bienvenue au pape je
vous parlais de 16 militaires ses
représentants auto tonnes un des
survivants des représentants provincial
fédéral est aussi des représentants de
l'église à tour de rôle ils vont venir
saluer le pape et strass khadija tout
puisque le souverain pontife va sortir
de la salle il va rencontrer brièvement
dans une rencontre privée le premier
ministre trudeau et la gouverneure
générale avant de quitter il va se
rendre par la suite au séminaire saint
joseph pour pouvoir se reposer je
l'avais d'une cérémonie très court on
parle d'environ 15 minutes ici et du
côté de l'archevêque de moncton bien sûr
et la décrit ce moment comme étant
historique je vous invite ce qu'il n'y
aura pas de discours officiel du pape
ici ses premières paroles seront
réservées demain lundi lorsqu'il va
rencontrer en personne des survivants
des pensionnats alors voici à ce sujet
l'archevêque de moncton qu'on écoute à
l'instant les mots qu'on espère bien
vous contribuez alors désir de
validation de leur expérience de fait
montré au monde l'importance de leurs
droits la beauté de leur culture de
leurs traditions et faire avancer la
guérison et la réconciliation parmi eux
et j'espère bien aussi au canada
alors évidemment il ya beaucoup beaucoup
de sécurité n'est ce pas autour de tous
ces événements de la visite du pape
bah oui c'est toute une organisation qui
a été organisée ici à edmonton on parle
de lourdes sécurité et membres de la grc
policiers on a vu un important cortège
déjà ici à edmonton et parlons de cela
il faut dire également l'état des routes
il ya certaines routes qui sont fermés
on parle de fermeture intermittente des
tronçons des autoroutes importante en
trop de sel queen elizabeth alors voilà
comment ça se déroule même devant
l'aéroport il y as sécurité qui est on
vraiment de de protéger qu'est ce qui
est en train de se dérouler voici dans à
edmonton merci beaucoup il dit n'être
pas l'on retrouve plus tard quand
l'avion du pape va atterrir merci alors
enjoint maintenant tiffany requêtes elle
se trouve devant le séminaire saint
joseph où le pape va séjourner pendant
son séjour à edmonton bien sûr à l'heure
tiffany parlez nous un peu de comment se
prépare à l'arrivée du pape
comme le douy lynette le disais on se
prépare vraiment en termes de sécurité
c'est vraiment comme ça que l'on peut
voir que le pape restera ici au
séminaire saint joseph le séminaire
saint joseph en fait c'est parti d'un
campus théologique à edmonton avec les
bureaux de l'archidiocèse avec un
collège théologique et généralement
c'est un campus assez ouverts mais comme
vous voyez derrière moi c'est plus du
tout ouvert maintenant on a établi des
grandes barrières de sécurité une très
forte présence de corps policiers qui
sont là avec les caméras de surveillance
des drones aussi qu'ils sont qui survole
ce séminaire est ce campus et c'est
d'ailleurs ici qui était le cortège part
papale avant qu'il vienne à à l'aéroport
dès maintenant très long cortège avec
des motos de la police beaucoup
d'officiels de l'église beaucoup de
sécurité aussi et ses deux petites
voitures fiat qui doivent accueillir le
pape lorsqu'il descendra de l'avion donc
beaucoup beaucoup de sécurité autour de
ses séminaire saint joseph où il va
rester et oui on a divulgué d'ailleurs
cet endroit que y est on a attendu la
dernière minute pour me dire où le pape
avait séjourné
oui pour des questions de sécurité
certainement peut être aussi des
questions liées à cette visite où on ne
veut pas vraiment publiciser et célébrer
le pape de pour cette visite là mais on
va avoir donc beaucoup de sécurité pour
ça on a très peu de détails sur comment
il quelles vont être les conditions de
son séjour au séminaire saint joseph je
vais quand même vous montrer un une
petite inscription qui va être qui va
accueillir le pape et qui est
significatif parce que ce séminaire
saint joseph se trouve devant une école
l'école michaëlle jean qui a mis en
place des rubans ou ses marques et
chaque enfant compte bien sûr tout ça
lié à ces enfants et ces sépultures non
marquées donc c'est ce message là qui va
accueillir le pape lors ce qui va
arriver de l'aéroport et ça c'est aussi
significatif pour edmonton tiffany
requête on vous retrouve plus tard merci
voyons maintenant notre reporter
nationale mathieu bouyer bonjour mathieu
bonjour alors vous vous avez suivi ce
dossier vous étiez en fait à kamloops
l'été dernier au moment de la découverte
des tombes anonymes d'enfants de passion
de pensionnat c'est vraiment un moment
charnière
on serait pas ici ce matin geneviève du
tt de ses découvertes à kamloops l'an
dernier il ya vraiment un avant et un
après kamloops bien sûr les communautés
autochtones savez depuis toujours que
des enfants n'étaient jamais revenus de
ces pensionnats la commission vérité
réconciliation avait aussi mises en
lumière les sévices l'aider c'est
carrément dans ces pensionnats mais dans
l'esprit collectif canadien il ya
vraiment un après un avant et un après
kamloops a déclenché un choc vraiment à
la grandeur du pays ça a déclenché aussi
des recherches partout au canada on a
découvert des tombes d'année au manitoba
saskatchewan alberta en ontario sur le
site d'un seul ancien pensionnat
saskatchewan 750 et une tombes anonymes
ont été découvertes a vraiment un avant
et un après kamloops c'était aussi le
déclencheur et alain krivine le disait
des excuses de la conférence des évêques
canadiens présenté ses excuses dans les
mois suivants en septembre 2021 et ça
bien sûr préparé les excuses papa qu'on
a d'abord entendu à rome et qu'on va
entendre ici cette semaine au canada
justement vous étiez aussi au vatican au
moment des premières excuses du pape
comment comment ont réagi les
autochtones de la délégation à ce moment
là ce que c'était suffisant pour eux ses
excuses
c'était clairement un pas dans la bonne
direction de liège mais ce n'était pas
suffisant pour reprendre un peu de
contexte pendant une semaine le pape a
écouté d'abord les témoignages des
survivants il a rencontré une délégation
métis une délégation inuits négation des
premières nations hui trois rencontres
séparées ou le pape a d'abord écouté ce
qu'avait à dire les survivants des
pensionnats les représentants
autochtones pour qu'il prenne toute la
mesure toute l'ampleur des sévices des
abus de la douleur reliée au pensionnat
douleur qui existent encore qui ont été
transmises de génération en génération
et c'est après avoir entendu ces
témoignages pendant une semaine que le
pape a présenté ses excuses un premier
pas mais pas suffisant parce que c'était
fait à rome et c'était clair dès le
départ avant même qu'ils se rendent à
rome les délégations tokten voulait
entendre ces mots chez eux l'eau ou les
abus ont été commis et c'est tout
l'objectif de cette visite cette semaine
au canada parlons nous parlons
maintenant du gouvernement fédéral c'est
pas pour rien que le premier est rude au
se soit déplacé pour accueillir le pape
parce que dans le fond le gouvernement
fédéral c'est le premier responsable du
système des pensionnats absolument le
grand frère a une politique très claire
d'assimilation dès la création du canada
et même avant en 1866 le gouvernement
avait une politique claire
d'assimilation hector langevin billy's
d'un gouvernement avec dalle est l
architecte du système des pensionnats et
on à déléguer l'administration de ces
pensionnats à l'église catholique mais
l'idée de base d'assimiler les enfants
elle vient du gouvernement fédéral
d'ailleurs on parle d' excuses papa mais
le gouvernement fédéral lui a déjà
présenté ses excuses et elio 14 ans le
premier ni stephen harper avait présenté
ses excuses en chambre à ottawa entre
autres devant des survivants devint
aussi celui qui était à l'époque le chef
national de l'assemblée des premières
nations phil fontaine qui a été vraiment
qui a porté ce dossier toutes ces vies
toute sa carrière pour aboutir à des
excuses papale finalement alors que
plusieurs responsables des pensionnats
au canada le gouvernement fédéral et
l'église était vraiment les deux
principaux acteurs de ce système de
stimulation des enfants taupes mathieu
gauthier ait banton merci pour ce tour
d'horizon nous avons au revoir
alors la visite du pape françois sera
suivi en sépare des milliers personnes
des premiers peuples ils sont très
nombreux à pouvoir se déplacer à le
faire à travers le pays pour aller voir
et l'écouter que ce soit à edmonton ou à
québec où il fera mercredi alors charles
bourgeois vous vous suivez un des
autobus de survivants des pensionnats
qui sont partis de regina ce matin et
qui sont maintenant en route pour
edmonton
oui absolument il ya trois autres buts
qui ont quitté regina ce matin au total
ce sont près de 150 survivants donc qui
prennent la route pour arriver ce soir à
edmonton ils sont accompagnés chacun
d'entre eux est accompagné par un membre
de leur entourage alors pour un soutien
psychologique ou en soutien logistique
ce matin avant le départ j'ai été de
m'entretenir avec plusieurs d'entre eux
mais nombreux parmi eux ont préféré ne
pas parler ou ne pas s'exposer devant la
caméra écarte cette visite rouvre des
cicatrices elle fait ressurgir de
nombreuses douleurs je me suis entretenu
notamment avec une survivante elle sape
end heaven hell à 72 ans elle avait les
larmes aux yeux ce matin le jour du
départ on peut écouter une partie de son
témoignage
[Musique]
sirois lapidaire on a un nom un petit
bol eastwood
situation soit un peu mieux terme sauf
ouais c'était elle peut elle explique
que c'est très difficile pour elle cette
visite parce que tu as fait ressurgir
des souvenirs mais il était important
dit elle de faire ça pour les personnes
qui sont rentrées dans les pensionnats
et qui malheureusement n'ont jamais pu
en ressortir
alors à l'est pardon à charge j'aimerais
qu'on parle maintenant des coûts de ce
voyage parce qu'on n'en connaît pas le
montant total mais on sait qu'ils vont
être partagés entre ottawa la conférence
des évêques du canada aussi
oui c'est ça ce sont les deux
principales sources de financement donc
la conférence des évêques catholiques du
canada vous la payez principalement pour
l'installation des événements liés à la
programmation c'est à dire concrètement
les scènes les sièges l'éclairage le son
l'accès à la connexion internet
l'hébergement du pape et de sa
délégation la sécurité des événements
pour le moment le président de la
conférence des évêques du canada
monseigneur raymond poisson ignore le
total ce que l'on sait également c'est
que ottawa finance à hauteur de 35
millions et parmi ces 35 millions il ya
30 millions qui permettent de suivre les
qui permet de 2,2 au survivant de suivre
ces événements que ce soit en physique
ou à distance il ya deux millions qui
sont consacrés à la traduction
simultanée des discours du pape ont fait
également que l'événement à québec
coûtera 3 millions de dollars au total
une petite question finalement pour
conclure ça parce que vous aussi vous
étiez à rome au moment des excuses
papale devant une délégation
d'autochtones mais
la raison pour laquelle il vient ici
c'est de le faire en territoire
autochtone ce qui est très significatif
pour eux
oui c'est à dire qu'à rome le pape avait
présenté ses excuses devant une
trentaine de survivants seulement donc
une délégation somme toute relativement
restreinte elle avait été bien accueilli
mais les survivants avaient été clair il
voulait que le pape vienne s'excuser sur
leurs terres au canada c'est d'ailleurs
l'appel à l'action numéro 58 du rapport
de la commission de vérité et
réconciliation et d'ailleurs ils bones
dont je vous parlais tout à l'heure ce
rappel du jour où le pape a présenté des
excuses elle était avec son fils et son
petit fils devant la télévision mais
elle voulait pouvoir vivre ça en direct
face à face avec 2 le pape françois
alors charles bourgeois on vous laisse
continuer de suivre ses autobus de
survivants en route pour edmonton merci
beaucoup bonne journée 3
alors isabelle je m'adresse à vous tout
de suite on vient de le voir cette
visite ses excuses sur place sont
attendus par beaucoup d'autochtones avec
énormément d'émotion mais il y en a
aussi parmi les autochtones les inuits
et métis pour qui c'est trop peu trop
tard pour qu'ils mènent c'est trop
douloureux humaines fasch ans oui
absolument c'est effectivement le
cueille il ya deux écoles de pensée je
pense y en a pour qui des survivants
autochtone pour qui c'est important
d'entendre les mots je m'excuse je
demande pardon au nom d'églises
catholiques par le pape il y en a
d'autres qui qui ne veulent rien savoir
en fait c'est aussi simple que ça vous
savez la guérison ses propres à chacun
c'est très personnel donc pour certains
oui on doit l'entendre et pour d'autres
ben il y aurait dû se passer bien avant
on le dit l'église unie au fait déjà des
excuses en 86 l'église un geek anglican
dans 93 le gouvernement fédéral en 2008
c'est un peu tard pour plusieurs il ya
beaucoup de peine ya beaucoup de
ressentiment alors on verra on verra ce
que ça va donner en bout de ligne mais
c'est pas tout le monde qui voit d'un
bon oeil ces excuses du pape
effectivement parmi les les survivants
des pensionnats ouais alors on va voir
tout au long de l'émission l'échantillon
si je puis dire de diverses réactions
autochtone mais là j'aimerais qu'on
revienne sur les excuses de l'église
comment expliquer on a dit on a dit
qu'il a découvert des tombes de kamloops
avait été le moment charnière
déclencheur mais pourquoi avoir pourquoi
at elle tant tardé l'enfant est une
question qui turlupine pas mal de gens
et moi sommes sur pas mal de début de la
semaine dernière lors j'ai parlé donc
quelqu'un que je connaissais qui était
au sein de l'église unie quand les unis
a décidé ça va faire on est en train
d'engloutir dans les années 80 en train
d'engloutir nous sommes considérables
dans les frais juridiques
l'argent ça vous n'allez pas chez avocat
qu'est ce qu'on fait c'est lui qui m'a
raconté sa formule et indjai on a décidé
collectivement les unit de ça c'est ça
que nous avons à faire face à la musique
on a changé notre équipe de juridique
nous ne vous vos avocats organisé nous
pour qu'on puisse faire des excuses en
bonne et due forme et la question
évidemment j'avais envie de lui poser
qu'est ce qui vous rend ce n'est la peur
la peur d'abord de la reconnaissance
d'un drame la peur du rôle et la
complicité et ultime à la peur pour ton
institutions va-t-on faire payer est-ce
qu'on va disparaître mais la réponse est
assez simple dans le fond c'est un bon
chrétien et des bains nous disparaîtrons
si nous avons commis de tels gestes si
nous en sommes coupables et c'est paris
qu'ils ont fait et le plus drôle c'est
que l'église unie est encore là bas ils
sont sur le point aujourd'hui ou demain
ou peut-être c'est ayant leur manque un
bout il est en train d'élire la première
leader de l'église unie autochtone
d'enfin glisse catholique ne l'a pas
fait si je suis vraiment ce que c'est sa
part par des coûts par peur de
réputation de l'église que je sais que
bâle cas de litige il dit c'était une
réflexion réelle et je me dis ensuite
arrive l'autre l'autre réflexion qui est
aussi très profonde c'est à dire est ce
que je suis capable de reconnaître que
j'ai commis ces gestes là je vous donne
un exemple je parlais la semaine
dernière avec une religieuse qui
extrêmement sympathique et qui me l
sa bande g réd à marier val saskatchewan
des pensionnats il y en a 10 mai nous
nous on est assure qu'on faisait la
bonne chose qu on pensait qu'on aide à
l'éducation des gens nous on est à sûr
qu'on allait les aider à avoir un
meilleur destin mais évidemment la
question c'est mais vous avez pas vu
qu'ils amenaient les enfants parfois
dans les automobiles à gérer ou dans des
autobus et que les enfants n'avaient pas
le choix
c'est un traumatisme même pour les
communautés religieuses les modèles aux
au delà vous allez voir ce qui va vous
dire c'est toute une histoire alors
parlons de traumatisme pour comprend
justement le drame des pensionnats leur
impact à long terme non seulement sur
les personnes qui leur vécu mais sûre
qu'ils ont vécu mais sur toute leur
communauté je jouais ce qu'on appelle ce
qui est convenu d'appeler un survivant
de pensionnat il est maintenant avocat
ex député fédéral d'abitibi baie james
nunavik eeyou roméo saganash bonjour
quoi monsieur saganash où je vive je
vous remercie d'accepter de revenir sur
ce passé douloureux vraiment là au nom
de la vérité dans le fond vous avez été
envoyé au pensionnat c'était de la tuque
en 1968 vous aviez sept ans comme tant
d'autres enfants vous avez été arraché à
votre famille ce jour là n'est ce pas
donc comme tout le monde et et c'est
humain thomas plein
dans nos mémoires
cette première expérience me souviens
très bien quoi que nous sommes arrivés
durant la nuit aux personnes de la tuque
à pleine nuit je me suis encore du
prêtre qui est en haut de l'escalier
d'un poignet qui nous parlait
j'ignorais à ce moment là si nous
parlaient en anglais ou en français
parce que je connaissais bien et 1 et
l'autre langue je ne parle que le christ
nous arriver à 7,1 alors il tend à
entraîner adressé et nous dire des
choses que personne dans les foyers
comprenait alors on suit de tous ces
détails je me souviens quand même la
santé de la place quand je suis arrivé à
moi et vos parents avez vous été parce
que certains parents on lit dans dans le
rapport commission de la commission
vérité réconciliation des dizaines et
des dizaines des milliers de témoignages
et il y avait des parents autochtone qui
voulait donner une éducation à leurs
enfants et qui acceptait de les donner
pour qu'il s'en aille au pensionnat
qu'elle est est ce que c'était le cas
pour votre famille vos parents
pas du tout rires je connais pas par an
surtout de ma communauté qui ont accepté
librement de laisser partir des enfants
certaines provinces certains pour ma
mère
ma mère a perdu sur ses 14 enfants a
perdu 13 des 14 sommets des précédents
c'est ce qui doit être extrêmement
douloureux pour une femme comme comme ma
mère qui maintenant décider les trois
ans maintenant
donc et dans les très rarement de la
journée que les enfants partaient
comment on libérait totalement les
villages d'enfants on a parlé puis les
sourires des rires les enfants qui
jouaient dehors
dans l'eau
ce bar de la rivière sera donc souviens
de tout ça et jusqu'à la fin de ses
jours
elle était très bénigne ça et ce
uniquement qu de l'entente sur les
patients qui étaient signés
avec les chutes sur fontaine
c'était une époque je pense que mon ne
pas compenser les parrains on accompagne
compenser les enfants qui ont fréquenté
ce personnage et non les paras et c'est
ce qui était le but
d'autant plus qu'un nom après votre
arrivée votre mère a perdu son conjoint
en fait votre père est mort un an après
votre arrivée n'est pas snob on vous a
refusé
de retourner dans votre communauté pour
assister à ses funérailles n'est ce pas
oui et je me souviens très bien de ce
mois de janvier matin il y avait un
système intercom d'un d'un pensionnat là
dessus que eux deux l3 et à chaque côté
filles et garçons et la journée qui ont
appelé la famille saganash au bureau du
directeur je savais c'était quoi la
nouvelle alors dans la même phrase de
prêter nous dit votre part est décédé
mais sans casser par ailleurs le
passionnel ne dispose pas de budget pour
vous envoyer chez vous pour pour les
services alors ça finit comme ça on n'a
pas pu dire un dernier au revoir mon
coeur de cette façon ne devance est
cette indifférence cette dureté
comment vous avez réagi à travers toutes
ces années au pensionnat je pense que
vous avez passé dix ans quel parti avez
vous adopté qu'est ce que vous avez fait
pour faire face à cette adversité
mais cette journée
spécifiquement lier un déclic en moi
j'ai réalisé soudainement même là je
sais pas j'ai réalisé soudainement que
j'étais pris là et que je n'avais au
choix et que fallait que j'aille le
maximum aux aides de cette mauvaise
expérience de ce cauchemar de ce
traumatisme que je vivais alors c'est ce
que j'ai tardé à tout au long de ma vie
ce déclic ma m'a permis de me fermer
d'avoir auprès du personnel ce
passionnant pendant deux ans je n'ai pas
laissé la parole à aucun d'eux où elle
par l'un d'eux a deux sortes qui ont eu
qu à quelque sorte parle de moi et par
la suite évidemment
eux qui voulaient nous enlever notre
langue maternelle
moi j'en suis sorti avec deux autres
langues plus de la maternelle alors ce
qui m'a permis de bien fonctionner dans
la société en général constructeurs mais
on se connaît aussi votre combat contre
l'alcoolisme monsieur saganash est ce
que vous le voyez justement cette
maladie comme une conséquence du système
des pensionnats
banlieue plusieurs conséquences pour
uniquement je pense que tout au long de
notre vie où vit avec ce trimestre
société que nous avons vécu et a
d'autant plus que ce qui s'y trouve est
malheureux et allen en a glissé un mot à
tout à l'heure ce que j'ai trouvé
malheureux dans les supposés excuses à
rome le 1er avril du père l'a pas du
tout des excuses et s'est excusé auprès
des noms de quelques pommes pourries ou
pour être plus direct quelques
pédophiles dans l'église
ne s'est pas excusé au nom de son
institution qui l'église catholique et
j'espère que cette fois et c'est ce que
mon attention doit se prêter à ça ah si
vraiment nous aurons des excuses pleine
et entière cette fois ci au nom de
l'église catholique c'est ce qui est
nécessaire sinon à
mémoire j'ai fréquenté un pensionnat
amical anglicane et
certaines qui ont fréquenté et
passionnant catholiques sont
probablement les rues de sa visite et
espère beaucoup de cette visite mais
j'espère qu'ils seront pas déçus mais
c'est saganash on le souhaite pour eux
merci beaucoup au revoir merci beaucoup
et bien voyons maintenant la version de
l'église canadienne parmi ceux qui font
partie de la délégation papale qui
seront de tout son voyage à travers le
pays le président de la conférence des
évêques catholiques du canada
monseigneur raymond poisson l évêque de
saint jérôme et du mont laurier j'en ai
parlé un petit peu je vais parler un
petit peu plus tôt cette semaine
monseigneur poisson bonjour bonjour
madame alors dites-nous est-ce que vous
pensez que le pape est prêt à
reconnaître la responsabilité de
l'église catholique comme institution je
pense qu il ya une association directe à
faire entre les propos du snep et qui
ont été tenus le 1er avril dernier à
rome était le lieu choisi par excellence
pour exprimer des excuses au nom de
quelques abus qui ont pu être faites par
des membres de l'église catholique et
surtout la participation au système des
pensionnats autochtones et je pense que
ça a été fait de bonne volonté
je pense qu on ne niera 'pour le moment
de la visite au moment de la visite
l'importance des excuses et je pense que
la visite vient m
inspirer un pas de plus en avant pour
qu'il y ait des gestes de réconciliation
chacun des événements étant un geste de
réconciliation
mais voyez vous faites allusion encore
une fois aux membres aux abus commis ou
quelques abus à vous de vous avez vous
dit commis par des membres de l'église
n'est pas l'église comme institution
le vatican n'est pas prêt à franchir ce
pas là ce n'est que moi je ferai une
différence entre des a vu que des
membres ont pu faire auprès d'anciens
élèves des pensionnats et la faute
collective de l'église de participer au
système des pensionnats autochtones ce
qui n'est pas nécessairement de cause
début mais qui est une cause
qu'aujourd'hui on n'accepte pas qui est
celle de nier la culture sortir les
enfants de leur famille nous vouloir
comme dit l'expression faire disparaître
la culture indienne amérindienne
autochtone de l'enfant alors sache
france qu'il ya une reconnaissance
d'ailleurs il n'y aurait pas eu ni nos
excuses ni la délégation avons mené la
visite du pape
s'il n'y avait pas cette reconnaissance
mais je pense qu'il faut faire la
différence entre les deux c'est à dire
les codes des bus psychologique sexuelle
ou autre et la collaboration système qui
est tout aussi négative mais cette
collaboration système si je peux me
permettre cette collaboration système
c'est celle de meaning leasecom 1,6
million oui maintenant il faut
comprendre que l'église catholique
c'est pas une multinationale avec une
seule tête en eau qu il pas et c'est
très très décentralisé c'était des
communautés religieuses qui sont tout à
fait autonomes qui ont participé je
pense de bonne foi à un système qui
avait été voté par un parlement qui
était le gouvernement fédéral ouais
alors à cette époque là moi j'étais pas
là vous non plus aujourd'hui on porte un
regard qu'on a raison de porter un
jugement et de vouloir corriger le tir
et présenter des excuses et faire des
gestes de consignations mais à cette
époque là il ya personne n'a levé un
drapeau alors ces communautés loeb il ya
des gens qui ont fait du début hélas
puis il ya le système qui doit vous
dites pour l'église catholique chaque
diocèse fait ce qu'il veut mais cela dit
il ya quand même le vatican et le pape
représente l'église il ya un devoir
moral de daffy remis à leadership de
dire quelque chose vous pensez pas que
les autochtones on sait que les
autochtones attendait ses excuses
demandées depuis très très longtemps
pourquoi avoir tellement tardé mais là
je pense qu'on est justement où confins
de deux conceptions du leadership je
veux pas jouer sur les mots dans
l'église et dans notre conception
occidentale il ya des leaderships ya des
vidéos chiffres fournis dans l'église
diocésaine et leadership universel et
fait craindre que les mêmes compétences
quand on parle de nos frères et nos
soeurs autochtone où je comprends très
bien sortent ces nations pour nation
pour eux le chef c'est le pape c'est
d'ailleurs le cas pour beaucoup de gens
chez nous dans le monde non autochtone
de l'hymen des occidentaux qui disait le
chef de lidia c'est le pas mais si on
est honnête avec soi-même le pape ne
peut pas et ne doit qu'au s'impliquer
dans toutes les décisions que l'église
est facteur ou d'arrivée il le fait
aujourd'hui
il le fait aujourd'hui parce que comme
évêque et il est responsable de l'unité
entre les évêques nous comme et beck on
l'a invité on le sensibiliser et j'étais
là depuis décembre 2019 à s'associer à
nous pour ce geste afin justement de
bien respecter cette conception et qui
n'est pas unique aux autochtones et
aussi à l'ensemble de la société gérait
canadienne à savoir que le pape ces
excuses sont importants parce que pour
nous il est vraiment le responsable des
évêques au canada il est le responsable
en un sens de l'église au canada
aujourd'hui
alors revenons maintenant vous allez
vous aviez aborder la question de
l'argent des sourds amassés pour aider
les survivants des pensionnats
autochtones
l'église avait perdu promis dès 2006 la
norma c'est pas mal
en fait c'était si je me suis bien 25
millions qui étaient promis or je pense
pas qu'on en a vu beaucoup plus que 4
millions il ya une déception énorme à ce
côté là aussi on réclame je sais que
tout récemment en septembre vous avez
promis forme de réconciliation la de 30
millions mais par rapport à ce qui était
promis dès 2006 ils n'ont vu que 4
millions sont 25 alors je dirais deux
choses la première je voudrais rappeler
ces sondes un contexte de 2006 et les
années suivantes vous savez avant la
découverte des cimetières accumule où
l'émotion n'avait pas gagné la
population en général et je dirais donc
n'avait pas gagné non plus l'ensemble
des communautés chrétienne catholique où
des catholiques on n'était pas très
sensibilisé y avait eu beau y avoir la
commission vérité réconciliation qui
avait déjà parlé de toutes façons de
l'existence des cimetières mais tant que
co ûts cette découverte lors l'émotion
n'a pas gagné la population ce qui fait
qu'au moment du règlement au moins
demander 25 millions de collecte you put
cette levée qui répondrait à une émotion
cette levée de fonds elle n'a pas été
réalisée on a fait un effort louable
c'est d'ailleurs été reconnue par la
cour ou un pc a été fermée comme
processus se fendent à la deuxième est
une chose que je veux vous dire c'est
que le fonds de 30 millions qui existent
effectivement été mis sur pied pour cinq
années qui était mis sur pied par les
diocèses du canada il a un avantage il a
pour but des projets qui ne sont pas des
projets de développement de l'église
mais des projets pour mieux se connaître
autochtones et non autochtones
communautés chrétienne catholique non
autochtone et réserve autochtone pour
mieux se connaître connaître leur
culture pour voir favoriser un aspect de
spiritualité ans en barrages où on a des
accrocs commun et puis où si sans doute
faire des mémorial par rapport à cette
histoire qui est tout à faire triste de
notre histoire récente du canada contre
les mémorials monument
entretien cynthia je sais pas mais c'est
vraiment des projets décidés localement
avec les bons maintenant parmi les
autres attentes face à cette visite du
pape des autochtones les attendent des
gestes concrets je pense entre autre
essentiel l'accès aux archives des
communautés religieuses promis par les
évêques en septembre 21 dans leur lettre
d' excuses
auront-ils plein accès aux documents aux
archives
liées au pensionnat alors il ya déjà eu
des accès mais limité en fonction du
fait que c'est archi là ne sont pas
concentrés à un seul endroit je vous ai
parlé des communautés religieuses
impliquées chacune peut en avoir lorsque
nous sommes allés à rendre notamment
cette année mars et avril on se dit
préoccupé l'exécutif de vérifier en rien
avant de revenir en recueille port des
archives cinq ans davy mme suu kyi sera
deuxièmement on a même vérifié à la
maison des oblats arabe la commune ou du
jura c'est la même situation c'est
vraiment le cas alors on a mis sur pied
un comité des jeunes quelques mois pour
aller rechercher c'est archi mais en une
limite qui est tout à fait légal dans le
sens on peut pas divulguer comme ça
publiquement at large au post expression
sans restriction par rapport à la vie
privée toutes les informations il faut
qu'elle comme un genre de processus qui
respecte la vie privée notamment des
gens qui me connaissent engagé ce
processus
le processus est à venir mais ce qui est
engagée c'est la recherche des archives
et la mise en commun je dirais de ses
archers au pouvoir avant les bonnes
classes ces bons numéros au point les
bonnes personnes à contacter pour lui
alors mais nous à nous engager
formellement lorsque ces questions
juridiques seront réglées a donné accès
aux autochtones qui font la recherche
oui mais il faudrait juste précise
ironise archives sadi carnot comme deux
catégories qui ne sont pas
nécessairement non perméables et les
archives des écoles elles-mêmes mais ça
ça veut pas dire c'est dans nos mains ça
peut être dans les mains de l'école
elle-même qui était propriété du goût je
ne sais pas je sais qu'il ya du travail
qui se fait de ce côté là nous serons
six et que du côté de l'église
proprement dit nos archives sont souvent
ce qu'on dit sacramentelle c'est à dire
que on notait d'abord si l'enfant avait
vécu sa première communion sa
confirmation en quelle année il était au
niveau de la catéchèse c'est des choses
religieuses qu'on notait on note des
points bulletin santé ouais alors il
faut faire comme les différences mais on
est à la recherche et on est encore
certains sont très très bonne
coopération entre les communautés
religieuses il dit d'armement une petite
question rapidement en cinq ans poisson
est il possible parlant des enfants
qu'ils aient été enterrés
sans rituels religieux sans acte de
décès à votre avis écoutez ça me
surprendrait beaucoup parce que d'une
part au niveau de la grande tradition de
l'église catholique et un immense
respect au niveau du décès de la mort du
corps humain un immense respect de
toutes époques de tous y est et s'est
récemment d'ailleurs que l'élise accepté
de l'incinération on a une immense
respect pour soi cependant face qu'il
faut se placer dans le contexte
historique
ces enfants l'eau venait de loin les
transports et les moyens de
communication n'étaient pas ceux qu'on
ait aujourd'hui mais surtout le climat
de vie dans la maison la qualité
d'hébergement de nourriture qui l'amène
pour les religieux et les religieuses
qui vivent avec eux c'est difficile
les maladies infantiles n'est pas ce
qu'elle est aujourd'hui
alors quand tu y arrives un décès je
pense faut qu'on attend une semaine je
pense pas qu'on déplace la personne pour
la ramener très loin comment faire je ne
sais pas alors on est dans le nez on est
dans la nébuleuse on cherche ensemble je
pense à vous prendre du temps de dire
sur ça il va falloir le faire dites-moi
monseigneur poisson concernant les
autres attendent des actes aptonia leur
retour la restitution des artefacts
autochtone au vatican pensez vous que le
pape vont rapporter avec lui
je penserais pas parce que ça veut pas
dire qu'il n'y en europe or c'est parce
que ce n'est pas du ressort du pape de
faire ça vous savez au à rome il ya une
compétence muséale
sectionnelles nous avons lors de notre
rencontre en mars avril avec les
délégations pris le temps de visiter
avec nos délégués des expositions nous
avons pris connaissance que dans
d'autres pays du monde particulièrement
du côté de l'asie il y avait eu du
travail de fait pour de la rétribution
restitution d'objets auprès des
communautés autochtones là bas mais
aussi il y avait eu des réactions chez
les communautés autochtones à savoir
normale à partir du moment où monsieur à
quoi ça servait combien de millions de
personnes par année voyaient leur
artefacts y en a qui ont décidé d'en
laisser parce que c'est quand même une
place publique une tablette
publicitaires incroyables que le musée
du vestiaire
avec les autochtones de chine ouais vous
dites là
on est encore parler d'accord parce
qu'il y en a qui estiment qu'ils ont
peut-être été volé ses actifs acclamé
comme vous dites c'est une question
d'obtenir condom on pourra débattre plus
tard une toute dernière question pensez
vous que les survivants des pensionnats
autochtones vont trouver dans les
excuses de paepe françois va leur faire
ces jours ci de quoi pardonner à
l'église et ses représentants sur vous
parler de mon expérience personnelle
avec eux lors de la délégation à rome
ce sont des personnes qui ont un respect
pour le saint père très grain pour les
aînés en général seront des personnes
qui ont énormément de respect pour la
nature humaine pour la personne telle
qu'elle est je pense qu'il va être bien
accueillie je pense que les excuses sont
importantes qu'on voyait faire écho sans
doute mais je pense aussi que chacun des
événements sera une occasion de
réconciliation et comme il ya beaucoup
d'intérêts de leur part pour participer
aux événements je pense que il y aura de
leur part beaucoup de satisfactions à
rencontrer l'homme a rencontré le pape
qui se prononce ce un clic désirent une
réconciliation véritable posent des
gestes vont dans des endroits très
significatif et va utiliser aussi grâce
à eux des symboles de leur culture je
pense qu'il va y avoir là deux traits
geste de réconciliation et que les
survivants comme vous dites survivra
survivants vont pouvoir trouver là une
certaine consolation on peut pas nier le
passé on peut pas tourner la page comme
ça on peut pas être facile ça on peut
aller plus loin ensemble et vous comme
moi on était pas lors les générations
passées il ya des gens qui vivent avec
des séquelles on essaie de réparer en
vivant un simple quelque chose de
meilleur monseigneur poisson je vous
remercie vous souhaite une bonne visite
papale au revoir merci beaucoup merci
madame alors avant de faire commenté
isabelle les allait au sujet de cet
entretien avec monseigneur poisson on
voit la viande du pape france fois dans
lequel il a voyagé les parties de rome
ce matin c'est un long long voyage de
plus de dix heures pour le pape qui
arrive à bord de l'avion de la compagnie
thai airways alors il bouge jusqu'à
l'aéroport où il sera attendu il est
attendu par une délégation à la fois
politique puisque monsieur trudeau doit
y être en compagnie de la gouverneure
générale du canada n'est saimone mais il
ya aussi des gens droits plaisantant le
clergé au canada dont
l'évêque denton je crois en tout cas on
aura l'occasion de le voir tout ce beau
monde là dans quelques instants puisque
le pape va sortir de cet avion et va
être accueilli par une très brève
cérémonie d'une quinzaine de minutes
avant de se resserrer pour aller se
reposer et faire face à cet horaire
chargé éprouvant et motif qu'il va vivre
au cours des prochains jours à commencer
par demain à eindhoven où il donnera
elle fournira des excuses sur le site
d'un ancien pensionnat on voit je crois
la le nonce apostolique ce monsieur avec
le chapeau rouge le nonce apostolique du
vatican au canada c'est en quelque sorte
l'ambassadeur du vatican au canada
d'ailleurs on ne verra pas le pape
sortir de l'avion vous savez peut-être
il n'est pas bien il a mal au genou
alors il va d'ailleurs se déplacer en
fauteuil roulant on va le voir le nonce
apostolique et le chef du protocole du
gouvernement canadien vont monter à bord
de l'avion en avant pour aller
accueillir du le pape pendant que
derrière à l'arrière de l'avion
lesquelles que 75 80 journalistes
accrédités pour couvrir cette visite
papale vont sortir donc par l'arrière
le pape lui ensuite sera descendu à
partir d'une plateforme il sera donc
déjà à ce moment là en fauteuil roulant
pour embarquer dans sa voiture en route
donc pour que je répète une très très
brève cérémonie d'accueil que nous
allons vous présenter bien sûr
alors je vous propose maintenant d'aller
chercher quelques réactions à ce que le
conte le président de la conférence des
évêques catholiques du canada a dit nous
a dit tout à l'heure concernant ses
excuses très attendu isabelle picard est
ce qu'il y avait dans ce que monseigneur
poisson a dit nous a dit quelque chose
qui
je sais pas moi vous donner un peu
d'espoir où vous a surpris
oui kim kim ho / prix qui m'a peut-être
un peu attristé ou même mis en colère
d'un certain sens quand il dit qu'il
faisait une différence entre
l'église et les quelques pommes pourries
à l'intérieur de l'église pour moi sauf
quand on parle de pensionnats
autochtones c'est indissociable c'est à
dire que j'ai entendu trop de
témoignages de gens qui disaient avoir
subi des abus on le sait sexuelles
psychologiques physiques
pour être capable de dissocier les deux
pour moi ça ça va ensemble et je pense
que si l'église ne reconnaît pas ça il
ya un problème c'est souvent ce qu'on
entend aussi de la part des survivants
on veut qu'on reconnaisse toute la
responsabilité de l'église et pas
seulement de quelques prêtres qui aura
eu des écarts de conduite comme on
l'appelle malheureusement trop souvent
ce ne sont pas des écarts de conduite ce
sont des agressions souvent qui ont été
commises il faut dire les choses comme
elles sont je pense que c'est le début
de la reconnaissance et des excuses
qu'on fait entendre de la part du pape
allait là dessus sur justement ses
excuses est-ce que
il semble pas vouloir reconnaître une
responsabilité de l'église comme
institution a sonné un peu chacun est ce
qu'elle est clair cette responsabilité
parce que ce que dit monseigneur poisson
c'est que l'église et n'est pas
hiérarchiser le panneau des pâtes à
mâcher du ruisseau ce serait quelque
chose de nouveau c'est pas léger pas
trahir ses mots quand même il dit
décentralisée
attendait là quand même camp malien tout
le monde connaît la bielle la pyramide
de l'église catholique en a pas tant que
ça dans les romans des religions qui est
bâti sur une pyramide aussi net que ça
vous élisez le chef et le chef y est
latent qui veut rester dans ce cas ci
j'attends ce jeu face à cette rude
depuis plusieurs années ah oui mais le
pape pouvait pas savoir toutes ces
choses là et de toute façon ça repose
sur la responsabilité des congrégations
religieuses qui était menacé ses toiles
je m'excuse mais le pape était
certainement que c'est pas un truc qui a
duré deux ans ça a duré au delà de satin
alors il apparaît comme un probable pour
ne pas dire impossible que quelque part
au vatican on n'a pas été mis au courant
de ce qui se passe à lille que tous les
cinq ans on appelle ça des visites ad
limina à tous les cinq ans les évêques
doivent se présenter à rome est racontée
puisqu'il parle dans leur diocèse dans
leur partie du monde et dans certains
cantons n'a que c'était joseph ratzinger
qui en était le patron de cette
congrégation l'un qui recevait tout ce
monde là il était dur il apparaît comme
totalement futile de s'imaginer que à
rome de 1880 quelqu'un aujourd'hui on
n'était pas au courant
quand on dit que le pape est capable le
col préfet de discipline au vatican est
capable de dire un évêque je te dénomme
est vrai que roupie on a fait le cas
avec le casino de bâle mais carrick on
lui enlève s'amarrer t il et on le rend
le tallec on est capable de prendre
française ne fait pas premières
centaines de fois trouver des gens qui
sont pas corrects dans l'église et les
défroquées ans vous dire qu'il ya un
pouvoir rien nonobstant à quel
congrégations religieuses vous
appartenez alors quand j'entends dire
que c'était fait leur gérer seul le
calmar et que l'elysée n'a pas réagi
c'est donc je m'excuse assez simple de
dire que l'église à rome kouchner ex
passé sur le terrain ici c'est chacun
attende encore produite cette espèce de
d'échappatoire qui consiste à dire
c'était pas un outil aux autres de
régler la fin alors juste alain je vous
interromps brillamment juste pour dire
aux gens bacon qu'on voit évidemment cet
avion qui transporte le pape françois ce
gars est donc allé report donne
maintenant on a vu brièvement auparavant
le premier ministre trudeau avec la
gouverneure générale du canada qui elle
même est d'origine autochtone c'est des
premiers peuples les teams ut mary
watson qui sera donc là elle aussi
partie de cette délégation qui va
accueillir le pape pour ses excuses tant
attendue et dont on a l'impression en
juger par réaction et des abeilles
picard et d'alain cruviers qu'elles vont
décevoir les communautés autochtones
isabelle je reviens à vous parce qu'on a
également parmi les attentes nombreuses
face à cette visite papale il ya donc
ses excuses la reconnaissance de la
responsabilité de l'église est-ce qu'on
entendra les excuses c'est demain matin
mais il ya aussi la tante de l'argent la
tente des archives qu'avez vous comment
avez vous réagi à ce que monseigneur
poisson le président de la conférence
des évêques qui nous a dit à cet égard
mais encore là c'est un début de quelque
chose on dirait qu'on est toujours dans
un début de quelque chose n'y a jamais
rien qui se passe il est encore jeune je
comprends pas pourquoi il y ajoutant des
obstacles juridiques des obstacles l'on
m'a donnée ça fait très longtemps qu'on
demande un accès aux archives il faut
rendre les archives disponibles il faut
mettre tous les moyens en place pour
pouvoir les recueillir et les rendre
disponibles plus que cinq jours parce
que c'est ce qu'on a pour le moment il
ya un homme un archiviste en vérité
réconciliation de vente au box est rendu
du côté de l'église à rome donc au
vatican et qui a eu accès pendant cinq
jours aux archives générales des oblats
et se trouvaient principalement ce sont
des photos il faudra beaucoup plus de
temps il faudra pour nous c'est
important pour les autochtones d'avoir
toutes les pièces du puzzle du casse
tête pour pouvoir les mettre ensemble
commence à identifier les gens justement
des tombes anonymes dans d'autres
lettres heures ce ne sont pas des
financières pour faire une différence
aussi le surpoids sont 10e c'est de sidi
cimetière dans un cimetière guen pierre
tombale bien ce n'est pas le corps et
donc ça on devrait faire en sorte que ce
soit accessible de façon générale pour
plusieurs personnes plusieurs archiviste
qui veulent justement mais tous ces
pièces du casse-tête là est finalement
arrivé à une des raisons parce que ça
passe par ce donc c'est pas anodin et
c'est très important oui puis vous
croyez que ces documents-là ses archives
qu'elle soit dans les anciennes écoles
qu'elles soient à rome où qu'elles
soient je sais pas moi la conférence des
évêques elles vont donner des
explications au sujet de
sépulture anonyme mais on espère en fait
on l'espère s'il donne pas il donne pas
mais au moins on ne refait tout ce qu'on
pourra pour vraiment savoir ce qui s'est
passé qui est mort comment il ya
tellement de choses qu'on ne sait pas
dans les communautés il ya tellement de
rumeurs si vous saviez et ça ça fait
partie de tout le fardeau qu'il porte
des survivants et pour alléger ce
fardeau là il faut justement connaître
les faits on dit souvent qu'à la
première victime quand il ya une
problématique comme celle des
pensionnats c'est la vérité on doit
commencer par la vérité avant même de
commencer à faire une virée s'en est
donc pour l'instant on n'a pas
l'impression allé brièvement vous aviez
une réaction là dessus
on est surpris de la déclaration de
celui qui est à la tête de la conférence
des évêques mais paradoxe paradoxe parce
qu'on pouvait en attendre plus le même
discours venant du cardinal la croix de
québec ce capital y en a quatre au
canada il y avait de plus la même chose
heureusement il n'a pas eu beaucoup des
personnages sur le territoire du diocèse
de québec j'ai pas me sentir interpellés
personnellement il a changé son fusil d
épaule il est là tantôt vous allez
peut-être sûrement le reconnaître mais
il dit maintenant qu'ils sont coupables
et il le dit de façon très claire nous
avons été complice et nous sommes
coupables dans des termes qui sont sans
équivoque ah c'est ça qu'on attend non
pas de celui qui est propriétaire du
diocèse nice des congrégations
religieuses ses fesses à ce qu'on attend
je passe de faire de point de vue
purement justice c'est que quelque part
dans les listes on adopte cette insulte
m'apparaît comme la seule à avoir nous
avons participé quelque chose qui est
horrible et nous sommes capables de ça
après ça peut-être qu'on peut parler de
réconciliation ménard auparavant alors
on y reviendra à la formulation de ses
excuses très certainement demain mais là
j'aimerais qu'on parle de la sécurité on
l'a abordée très brièvement tout à
l'heure avec nos collègues sur place
parce qu'on peut dire que le pape c'est
une des dix personnes les plus protégés
au monde alors sa visite au canada on
sait ce faisceau sécurité j'en parle
avec l'ex directeur général adjoint de
la sûreté du québec marc savard bonjour
bonjour alors dites-nous d'abord qui
supervise la sécurité du pape parce que
j'imagine qu'elle est police locale il y
à il ya aussi une les gardes du corps la
sécurité immédiate du pape ses propres
gardes de corps sans doute mais qui est
responsable du team ans qui va prendre
les décisions en cas de pépin
en fait il faut séparer la protection
rapprochée donc à quelques pieds
quelques mètres du pape il ya
certainement ses propres gardes du corps
mais il ya toute la protection
l'environnement la gestion et la
gouvernance c'est la grc vous savez je
voudrais juste faire le petit
commentaire suivant vous avez le défi
actuellement dans la protection qui l'on
doit offrir aux pattes c'est le fait que
cette notion de défi de protection de
sécurité ne doit pas prendre toute la
place par rapport au fait que le pape
bien pour dans un but précis il ne faut
pas que cette protection soit tellement
visible que le reste va devenir
secondaire et c'est tout un défi parce
que la protection elles mêmes vont être
d'une ampleur qui est rare qu'on n'est
pas habitué est actuellement vous
l'avait bien dit madame asselin c'est le
pape quand on regarde tous les palmarès
c'est la personne dans les dix personne
n'est plus protégé au monde donc cette
nation de protection de risques parce
qu'on parle de risque bien entendu elle
doit être là elle doit avoir l'emploi
qu'il faut elle doit pas prendre toute
la place pour que ce ne soit que son
convoi
alors est-ce qu'on a une d2 ce que ça
peut coûter tout ça ce dispositif de
sécurité pour le canada en tout cas
puisqu'il en a sur une partie très
certainement
et on parle de plusieurs millions de
dollars vous savez quand on est dans une
notion de sécurité comme ça où il y aura
déploiement de multiples agences que ce
soit des agences de sécurité privées que
ce soit les services policiers multiples
on parle de plusieurs millions et
rappelons-nous le sommet des amériques
que ce soit le sommet de la francophonie
on parlait de plus de 20 25 millions bon
maintenant est-ce que ça ira à cet
auteur je ne crois pas parce que
évidemment il n'ya qu'une personne c'est
le pape dans les autres événements que
je viens de mentionner on avait vraiment
plusieurs personnes plusieurs
dignitaires qui arrivait avec aussi
leurs propres préoccupations de sécurité
donc déjà l'ampleur est beaucoup plus
difficile beaucoup plus grande donc on
va parler de plusieurs millions mais
vous savez il ya des discussions en
effet quand on est dans cette
planification dans la réalisation de la
mission maintenant on n'est plus
vraiment dans la planification on est
dans la réalisation des missions
ce n'est pas le temps de se poser la
question est ce que cette action cette
réaction qu'on va voir va coûter trop
cher où on est capable de diminuer on va
mettre en place ce qu'il faut avec
l'expérience aux énormes et puis on va
assumer les coûts et après on réclamera
qui de droit il y aura tous des massages
interrompre ce savoir juste deux minutes
pour vous dire que ça c'est la petite
fiat qui va chercher
le pape au pied en fait aux pieds oui de
l'avion parce que le pape va être
descendu sur une plateforme mécanisée en
fauteuil roulant pour ensuite
s'installer dans la fiat où il sera
transporté jusqu'au hangar de l'aéroport
ce qu'on voit maintenant c'est le nonce
apostolique donc le l'ambassadeur du
vatican au canada qui accompagné du chef
du protocole du gouvernement canadien se
rendent donc à bord de l'avion pour
accueillir salué le pape qui par contre
ne sortira pas de ce côté ci est ce sa
sortie se fera en principe à l'abri des
caméras jusqu'à ce qu'il se retrouve
dans le hangar mais ce salaire je
reviens à vous
j'imagine que la sécurité du pape
représente d'importants défis entre
autres parce que il y aura des milliers
personnes autour de lui je pense au
stade où il veut faire la messe à
edmonton mercredi ou au lieu de
pèlerinage du lac sainte anne où il y
aura quelques quinze mille peut-être
beaucoup plus que ça autour de lui céder
défi
oui ce sont des défis ce sont des défis
qui pour les policiers de main quand on
a une présence dans la dans le pub dans
la population où on voit circuler avec
la population on va se présenter ça
devient très très très risqué pour
évidemment la sécurité pour eux dans
leur tête ce sont les dossiers les plus
à risque bon évidemment il y aura toutes
les mesures de sécurité pour essayer de
cibler de vérifier les personnes qui
vont entrer en contact avec le père ou à
tout le moins qui vont être dans un
environnement
qui est relativement restreint exemple
le stade à edmonton c'est un
environnement restreint on est capable
de sécuriser me sauver la sécurité ce
n'est pas absolue il ya des risques ils
vont toujours existé et pour les gens il
ya tout un arrière scène à cet aspect de
sécurité j'ai regardé le petit véhicule
la fiat qui arrivait
il faut imaginer que ce petit véhicule
depuis qu'il est en territoire canadien
je suis imaginé qu'il a été sécurisé il
a été sous contrôle permanent avec des
gars y'a rien qui est laissée aux ouah
je m'excuse mais on voit que le pape est
arrivé vous suivez les images comme moi
d'abord on a aperçu le pape moi je les
ai vus boitant en sait il ya des
problèmes au genou là on voit à gauche
le cardinal de québec le cardinal marc
ouellet qui fait partie de l'entourage
du pape allez y je vais vous laisser
décrire les yeux c'est la série lourde
oui
on a donc le cardinal quelle espèce de
secrétaires d'état mais ses paroles in
c'est lui que vous voyez dans le milieu
qui a l'air de contempler l'asf a
déclaré la mère se relevant
et à côté afin que vous avez le
secrétaire d'état le secrétaire d'état
aux secrétaires d'état d'un point de vue
notre religiosité je reste le numéro un
incontesté c'est lui mais il est aussi
accompagné ces gros la secrétaire d'état
y est accompagnée de substitut qui lui
s'occupe de tout le secrétariat du pape
c'est à peu près le seul personnage qui
peut rentrer dans le bureau du pap sans
avoir cogné à la porte j'exagère mais
athènes et puis à côté vous avez
monsieur gallagher le quai ou six
évêques mais qui n'est pas avec la barbe
oui c'est ça
lui sait les relations avec les états au
vatican le saint siège du tout faudrait
comme ça a des relations avec quoi 180
quelques pays dans le monde plus que le
canada donne un entretien avec des états
étrangers c'est c'est un service de
diplomatie colossal peut-être le plus
vieux services de diplomatie qui
existent sur la planète on est le
terreau lourde que vous voyez là le défi
lycée c'est la gouvernance caris oui
alors là je vous propose à l'est on va
revenir là dessus vous allez me dire
vous allez me dire en fonction de tous
ces gens qui ont voyagé de près dans la
garde rapprochée de monsieur de monsieur
le pape vous dire ce que ça veut dire
que si ça me donne annonce quelque chose
sur l'importance de sa visite et sur la
nature des excuses qu'il fera demain je
vous propose en attendant d'aller
joindre dans l'avion un des journalistes
qui voyageaient avec le pape il était
donc
il représente le quotidien la croix
c'est ce journal qui couvre l'actualité
religieuse et catholique loubet mancelle
ville bonjour vous êtes encore à bord de
l'avion dit nous est ce que le voyage
s'est bien déroulé est ce que le saint
père est venu vous voir reste que vous
aviez
bonjour oui alors effectivement je suis
encore dans l'avion dont vous en parlait
encore un peu de bruit tout autre on
était en train d'étendre le voyage s'est
bien déroulé il a duré donc plus de dix
heures de pied rome ce matin et piment
au début du vol n'a pas de françois
revenus talus et borna dit
il leur a bien maintenant et puis il est
venu nous saluer un parent en marchant
avec des cannes donc voilà il a pris le
temps qu'elle dans une terre pour vous
savez un par un voilà ce qui nous a
plutôt surpris on s'attendait pas à ce
matin floor de cette manière et c'est
plutôt une bonne indication sur son état
de santé ben oui c'est ce que j'allais
vous demandez bon il a 85 ans et qu'il a
des problèmes aux genoux mais c'était
très important pour lui de faire ce
voyage parce qu'il en a annulé un en
afrique un peu plus tôt
oui absolument faire un voyage auquel le
pape françois tient beaucoup
d'abord parce que je pense qu'il a été
touché par les délégations d'autochtones
son 2005 mars début avril à rome et tu
la deuxième raison c'est que c'est le
pape est particulièrement sensible à
cette thématique des indigènes des
d'autochtones qui l'a bien connu en
amérique latine à la bouenza rs
lorsqu'il était archevêque en argentine
donc voilà c'est quand même un thème qui
le touche particulièrement et qui peut
expliquer eh bien pourquoi il est là et
pourquoi il a entrepris il appelle un
écrivain dans voyage une porte elle
pendant ces quelques jours à partir
d'aujourd'hui cela dit va se ménager des
moments de repos je pense que son
horaire là va prévoir toujours
déchaîné des activités pas trop longue
voilà absolument fait après midi il a
prévu de se reposer il est au celi merde
edmonton et puis demain voilà il aura
une rencontre le matin ils rencontrent
l'après-midi paie plus pour un programme
allégé comparé à d'autres voyages même
si le pape a prévu au cours de ce voyage
de prononcer un coup de prendre l'avion
à trois reprises de
l'intérieur monsieur paiement s'est levé
je la vends votre opinion vous qui
couvrent et de très très près les choses
vaticane
l'entourage du pape son entourage le
seui ton je pense que je veux qu'on
conduit au vatican donc le 15 pardon la
fuite la suite voilà la suite la suite
dit tout qu'est-ce que ça n 6 à ceux qui
voyagent toujours avec ces personnes la
parole in parraga la guerre et tout ça
ou si ça a dit quelque chose sur la
nature des excuses qu'il va faire ou
l'importance qu'il accorde à cette
visite
non écoutés ils voyagent toujours un peu
avec les mêmes collaborateurs
techniques si on peut dire santé de ses
régulières la sécurité et puis en
partant de deux collaborateurs qui sont
plus politiques diplomatiques ou je suis
qu'à l'instant le cardinal parole ils
ont fait venir gallagher et gardénia
parra les deux locaux on peut dire de
l'étape ce sont deux cardinaux le père
donald fermin et le cardinal wallet qui
sont tous les deux canadiens et donc
effectivement leur présence montre qu'il
apporte il accorde une importance
particulière à ce voyage et voilà ça ça
montre aussi qu'il a pris avec lui les
personnes à qui connaître le pays icône
est la situation ouais est ce que vous
attendez bon vous avez couvert bien sûr
les premières excuses autochtone fait à
rome en avril dernier est-ce que vous
vous attendiez à ce que celle qui nous
présentera demain
soit différente dans dans la face on les
dit on qu'il aille plus loin sur la
responsabilité de l'église
ok je fais pas de filière a plus loin
sur le fond ce que je peux vous dire
c'est que pour ce pape les gestes les
symboles ça compte beaucoup et donc le
fait qu'ils viennent au canada pour
présenter des excuses aux survivants aux
gens qui n'ont pas pu les entendent pas
pu être
à rome un parent de connexion voilà
c'est déjà un geste est très important
et après et qu'il accomplira des gestes
particulier que ce soit je suis pas eu
d'arrivée des objets authentiques
que ce soit dans votre âge suis
incapable de vous dire et voilà que le
sympa pour qu il les
jette un peu oui alors donc parce que on
sait qu'à rome le pape avait reçu des
autochtones émanent les autochtones un
cadeau un porte-bébé traditionnelle
autochtone alors on ne sait pas vous ne
savez pas si le pape en retour à
l'intention de leurs enfants elles
montrent peut-être de restituer des
artefacts exposé au musée du vatican
rien ne l'a annoncé en tout cas il ya eu
aucune annonce en ce sens qui a été fait
par le vatican donc quoi vous répondre à
ça on ne peut pas l'exclure ce qui est
sûr c'est que le swap contrats et est
conscient de cette problématique des
artefacts et peut-être pas les matinées
des musées donc voilà ce que je peux
vous dire
aujourd'hui sur ce sujet alors nous
demandent de stand vigeois merci
infiniment de nous avoir parlé
aujourd'hui et bon repos avant vous
aussi la couverture qui commence demain
merci beaucoup merci à vous
alors on voit évidemment cette petite
fiat blanche qui conduit le pape
françois qui est descendu donc de
l'arrière de l'avion qui se déplace je
voudrais je vous le rappelle en fauteuil
roulant on voit les nombreux gardes du
corps monsieur savard je sais pas si
vous êtes toujours là
malheureusement ce savoir mais j'aurais
posé une question sur la sécurité tous
ces gens-là déployer de toute évidence
des gardes du corps voilà le fauteuil
roulant ne pas le pape doit se déplacer
en fauteuil roulant on l'a entendu il
est bien là et rendre il est bien allé
voir les journalistes à l'arrière de
l'avion debout avec sa canne mais je
pense qu'on va le ménager
pour qu'il soit en forme pour les
grandes les grandes journées qui
l'attendent
au cours de la prochaine semaine tous
ses déplacements
alors je laisse un peu les images
parlent et j'imagine que ça c'est le
drapeau du vatican à l'est cette espèce
de fanions jaunes et blancs sa vie la
vie d'un garde du corps pour un parc ou
celui là c'est pas drôle on la vit au
brésil où il peut baisser sa fenêtre
comment ça jase avec les gens débarquer
de la voiture il le fait moins tu vas
essayer de moules a finalement il le
fait moins maintenant à cause de son
état de santé mais c'est un pas
surprenant qu'ils mettaient la sécurité
bien loin derrière
new york brésil et ailleurs et fiat mois
la rumeur que santander début de semaine
a fait quelques semaines c'est qu'ils
limousine je m'intéresse à s'arrêter
significatif de son état de santé parce
qu'il n'a jamais accepté la limousine il
prend la fiat 500 x alors le x ray
contre x et le modèle un peu plus large
mais quand même dans un état sans quoi
je vous interromps alain simplement pour
décrire un peu ce qui se passe qu'on
voit mais oui les fans la gouverneure
générale du canada elle même fini
s'adresser accueillir le pape sans toi
alors il ya une york il a 13 ans dans
cette délégation de gens qui attendent
le pat vous avez vu donc personne mais
en général justin trudeau mais il ya
aussi le grand chef de la confédération
des premières nations du traité 6 je
m'adressais et isabelle picard isabelle
qui est ce monsieur oui mais en fait
elles sont non je le connais pas mais
effectivement
emden et est basé sur le traité numéro 6
et de ce que l'on comprend c'est le
représentant de l'ensemble des
provocations de l'alberta il s'appelle
grec desjarlais or voilà voilà j'avais
son nom avait échappé et donc il est là
au nom de toutes les premières nations
ont finalement de l'alberta c'est le
équivalence et voulait du soleil picore
du québec
vous avez remarqué à la première
personne à qui il a serré la main si la
gouverneure générale oui la deuxième
dynastie michel en chef le troisième
prix un autochtone notre audois
quatrième alors je sais pas si c'est
dans la politique normal si dans l'oeuf
mais je me demandais hakim
hauts-de-seine et la mairie la deuxième
personne que j'ai pas pu identifier
une source intéressante puisque c'est
dans l'ordre des choses est ce que pour
vous dire mais je me demandais ce qu'il
esquisse est ce que ce seront les les
gens les premiers peuples qu'il saluera
d'abba ah oui mais ça sonne le bien du
club alors pour avoir une vue plus large
de ce qui se passe là-bas rejoignant
notre collègue qui est sur place will
dean est paul alors on voit la
gouverneure générale le premier ministre
trudeau qui sont assis bientôt le pape
s'assoira au milieu alors oui il dit
n'être dites nous un peu ce qui
s'apprête à se passer là dans cette
cérémonie qui va être très courte
ouais exactement jeune fille est une
cérémonie qui va durer une quinzaine de
minutes elle a déjà commencé vous savez
vous l'avez mentionné gouverneur général
le premier ministre eut d'eau
accompagnées ou s'il a vu grand chef de
la première nation de la confédération
ce traité fils qui ont accueilli le pape
dont voilà le salut militaire qualité
paie vous voyez le pape qui est assis au
centre justin trudeau et finalement la
gouverneure générale voilà à présent que
les musiciens hurun d'honneur est
tellement beau je vous propose de
prendre quelques instants de silence
pour écouter ce début de ce champ
d'honneur
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ouais
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oui
l'âme
abba
ah ah
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et
oui
[Applaudissements]
ouais
alors
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
m
à
[Musique]
oh
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
allez
elle
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
à
ouais
[Musique]
m
[Applaudissements]
non mais
alors voici les tambours autochtones
pour accueillir le pape will dean est
alors bye alors voilà vous pouvez vous
nous décrire uddin hâtez-vous on ne
mesure d'identifier les personnes qui
sont en train de saluer
le pape et la gouverneure générale
- d'abord j'aimerais juste vous dire
geneviève que c'est la nation elixis
laquerre ouvert cette cérémonie
officielle avec ses chants de tambour et
là on sait qu'avec des représentants
autochtones des dignitaires qui avait
été bien choisis et là on voit sans
doute un grand chef et on sait qu'il ya
des survivants des pensionnats pour
autochtones qui sont ici là sur place
qui salue à tour de rôle le pape après
cela il y aura d'autres représentants
qu'ils vont s'élever également le table
on parle donc de représentants de des
provinces et aussi
je vous interromps parce qu'on voit le
vol qui lui remet quelque chose oui oui
ça ressemble à un collier je te voici
zabel pourrait nous aider ça semble être
un collier brodé oui malheureusement je
me rappelle très bien oui effectivement
je pense que c'est un collier a âprement
fait en hausse à défaire le fait avec de
l'os donc si typique des cadeaux qu'on
offre aux gens
est ce que c'est une signification
particulière pour ma connaissance c'est
un objet d'ornement donc ça fait partie
évidemment des objets qu'on offre qui
font partie de la culture matérielle
autochtone de façon générale mais
généralement le peuple romain chapelet
béni finalement on l'a vu remettre dans
la petite boîte rouge là c'est
probablement un chapelet béni alors
d'accord alors on voit les chefs faria
plusieurs chefs qui était invité à ceux
à cette cérémonie d'accueil il y avait
des survivants aussi alors mais parmi
les chefs donc avait celui de la
confédération des premières nations du
traité 6 il y avait le chef de la
première nation de frog lake celui de la
première nation d'alexander et il y
avait donc des survivants j'en ai un
deux trois mois je compte trois
survivants qui étaient invités à venir
rencontrer le pape personnellement donc
à son arrivée à edmonton
isabelle je sais pas si vous avez eu une
réaction moi j'ai pensé en voyant ces
trois personnes assis sur le fauteuil en
train d'écouter les tambours autochtone
je voyais le gouvernement canadien
l'église et la reine oui c'est passe ou
ça vous avez éprouvé quelque chose en
les voyant cela effectivement et la
reine qui représentait on le sait par la
gouvernance générale qui elle-même et
inouk donc qui vient du nunavik cents
soit c'est une première c'est historique
sinon je suis très content de voir des
femmes aussi qu'ils sont là et pas
seulement des grands chefs vous savez
que dans la gouvernance autochtone les
femmes sont moins présents mais elles
ont été des survivantes importantes et
des témoins importants en tant que mère
de famille en tant que survivants des
pensionnats donc de voir des femmes aux
frictions présent pour moi ça c'est un
symbole une symbolique qui est vraiment
forte
alors c'est sale et les différents chefs
représentants autochtones
et on voit tout de suite l'interprète
derrière on peut présumer que c'est une
femme qui parle plusieurs langues
autochtones qu'en pensez-vous à moins
que il ne s'adresse au pape en anglais
oui d'après moi ça peut être en anglais
mais six essais des aînés c'est possible
qu'ils le fassent dans leur langue
également bien sûr
moi je dirais je sais pas ce que vous en
pensez à l'ats isabelle que le phare pas
l'air plutôt en forme pas trop trop
fatigué son voyage il a peut-être dormi
en avion maintien qui est habitué de mon
nom c'est pas c'est pas sa foi mais ils
sentent écoutés
annuler des voyages précédemment on sait
pas ce qu'il fera des prochains voyages
ya tenu à être ici dans des
circonstances très particulières
c'est un pèlerinage normal je pense que
c'est l'aboutissement le début de
quelque chose d'important pour lui
j'imagine
le protocole semble être un peu plus
allégée
sirène oui mais c'est donc parce qu'on
parlait de la gouverneure générale mais
elle est quand même un représentant de
la reine mais la reine est quand même la
chef de l'église anglicane
des symboles avec son mojo pourrait la
pression de bien des manières
il faut deux protocoles allégé moi je
pense que c'est nécessaire ça doit se
faire à l'image des premières nations
qui sont pas dans tout ce protocole très
chargé très lourd si on veut vraiment
créer la rencontre il doit y avoir un
protocole culé j'ai effectivement je
veux dire c'est curieux parce que bon on
aura l'occasion d'y revenir mais cet
homme là un passé qui permet de croire
qu'il ya une certaine sincérité dans
cette allée jemappes auto colère si
j'ose dire cette chose pour nos crs on
disait qu elle est visitée dans les
bidonvilles et qui partait en autobus
etc et ou en métro ils le faisaient
régulièrement j'ai suivi ses traces
l'abum apprécié de voir si tout ça
c'était vrai je pense qu'il est à l'aise
il est confortable si vous me permettez
l'expression
avec ces situations-là de réciprocité
ces belles foules me semble pas aussi
difficile prenez benoît ça c'est pas
feint de dire ça mais je me suis donné à
16 dans le pack mobile place
saint-pierre prendre un bébé c'est pas
évident denis des bisous donner des
m'incite pas aussi claire mais dans son
cas à lyon vainqueur plaisir réel
habituellement à rencontrer des gens
alors je pense qu'il ya quelque chose là
dedans qui est peut-être de l'art de la
simplicité pour lui l'homme et il faut
se méfier de des apparences là c'est
quand même un sujet un peu délicat si on
parle de 6,9 le début de la rencontre
par un drame historique
isabelle j'aimerais qu'on parle on a
évoqué tout à l'heure avec louis bémont
de senneville qui étaient à bord de
l'avion qui qui en qui le correspondant
de la croix au vatican de ces artefacts
que la délégation autochtones au mois
d'avril avait vu découvert pour certains
d'entre eux ils ont découvert le nombre
la quantité d'artefacts d'un budget
autochtone que le vatican exposé en
partie seulement dans son onze et
ça aussi c'est important la restitution
au moins de certains d'entre eux non
oui je pense que c'est vraiment
important les gens qui avaient été donc
délégué autochtone qui avait été
déléguée au vatican
en avril dernier en bars en fête avait
été un peu choqués on peut ébranler à la
vue de tous ces artefacts le parce que
vous savez que c'est un symbole
important de rapport de force aussi
au-delà du simple artefacts est ce que
ces artefacts ont réellement été donné
en cadeau ou est ce que justement ce
rapport de force leur cave l église où
l'emprise qu'avait l'église sur les
peuples autochtones on peut faire en
sorte que bon ça c'est fait d'une façon
qu'ils ont moins délicate et ce retour
des artefacts là ça vient avec justement
tout cet élément de réappropriation des
cultures des langues de la spiritualité
c'est pas seulement des éléments
d'identité ou des éléments non matériels
qui ont été volés mais il ya des choses
matérielles aussi et le retour de ces
artefacts l'heure ça serait un symbole
je pense extrêmement important pour les
communautés autochtones qui à travers
ces artefacts qui certains n'avaient
jamais vu ces articles nous mêmes dans
leur commune on y découvrait oui oui
donc donc c'est extrêmement important et
ça permet de comprendre aussi la vision
du monde lors l'histoire la culture donc
si ce n'est pas simplement des éléments
de culture matérielle autochtone c'est
bien plus vaste débat public plus large
que ça oui parce que pour revenir au
pensionnat je peux pas m'empêcher de
penser à tous ces objets avec lesquels
certains les enfants étaient envoyés des
objets personnels paris on a des des
mocassins des vêtements brodés par leurs
parents leurs grands parents que les
envoyer à l'école mais mais mais qui
finalement se faisait arraché tout ça en
arrivant au pensionnat oui absolument et
la plupart vous savez ils ont été
carrément brûlé c'est carrément ce qui
s'est passé parce que la symbolique elle
était important ce que ce que l'église
voulait dire c'est à partir du moment où
je mets les pieds dans le pensionnat où
tu n'es plus indien donc on va brûler
tout ce qui fait lundi en toi y compris
bien sûr des vêtements les mocassins ça
peut être des vestes en cuir vont être
les terreurs de la fourrure ecce terra
est donc symbolique qui est important
est de voir tout ça à rome mais il ya un
espèce de l'enfance s'y opposent et des
plusieurs autochtones
alors là on on voit que la cérémonie
comme promis était
et déjà terminée le pape maintenant est
en route pour
l'archidiocèse d'être menten où il va
séjourner où il va séjourner
le temps de son passage dans cette ville
albertaine qu'il quitte je crois
mercredi soir ou jeudi matin bardon
mardi soir ou mercredi matin en route
donc pour québec
alors oui il dit n'être on sait que le
pape se déplace donc maintenant dans sa
fiat et que son parcours jusqu'à
jusqu'au à l'archidiocèse se fera sous
haute sécurité des rues sont barrées ou
si je crois
fonds fermé oui exactement jeune fille
avait coûté et oui oui des routes
fermées là et aussi des tronçons
d'autoroute qui sont fermées alors on le
sait qu'il ya une lourde sécurité en ce
moment pour la venue du pape françois on
avait parlé d'une cérémonie très brève
ça tire à sa fin parce que là on a vu
tout juste là il ya à peine quelques
secondes le peuple françois quitté avec
le premier ministre et la gouverneure
générale mais il va avoir une petite
discussion privée avec le premier
ministre trudeau et la gouverneure
générale et par la suite il va quitter
vers le séminaire saint joseph où il va
se reposer vous l'avez vu ça a été très
court aujourd'hui
un peu de changement s'attendait à ce
que chaque personne à tour de rôle vient
de voir le pape échange de poignées de
même on a vu aussi qu'il ya eu échange
de quelques mots entre sept délégués
qu'ils étaient ici à l'aéroport d'amman
tonnes revenons si vous voulez très
rapidement là on parle du grand chef de
la confédération des premières nations
qui étaient là on a vu des décennies des
survivants des pensionnats pour
autochtones
on a aussi vu la chef de l'assemblée des
premières nations roseanne jallet vu nos
vins de mobilier oui oui oui oui je les
ai vus elle a salué le pape elle a salué
aussi le premier ministre elle était bel
et bien sur place la chef archibald et
il y a eu bien sûr des représentants de
l'église qui étaient présents ici lors
de cette série on a ça j'ai été très
court oui j'ai vu mon seigneur poisson
là justement avec qui je me suis
entretenu cette semaine le président de
la conférence des évêques catholiques
qui est donc arrivé j'imagine de québec
pour se rendre à edmonton et qui se
trace du reste du voyage du pape dans
toutes ses activités je veux poursuivre
et will dean est
oui alors beaucoup de personnes
aujourd'hui geneviève qui étaient
présentes pour l'accueil officiel du
pape en sol canadien et on termine
également avec des représentants de la
province néo de la municipalité est là
qui étaient sur place juste devant
lui je vous interromps brièvement je
n'exclus où il dit n'être encore une
fois ce parce qu'on nous montre les
images de l'avion à bord duquel le pape
a voyagé mais juste pour dire que c'est
cet avion qui est un airbus 330 dans
lequel ne pas va voyager dans tous ses
déplacements canada que ce soit donc
vers la ville de québec où que ce soit
donc vers iqaluit au nunavut à la fin de
son séjour il est censé décoller de là
bas alors on peut s'interroger ça
surprend plusieurs personnes on y
reviendra très certainement donc le pape
en principe embarque dans dans non pas
sa papamobile mais dans sa fiat à
destination disiez-vous du séminaire
saint joseph ou s'il est déjà en train
de s'entretenir avec monsieur trudeau et
la gouverneure générale
mais là ce qu'on sait c'est qu'on l'a
vue des play se déplacer vers l'arrière
c'est une petite salle privée où il y
aura un échange de quelques mots et
c'est tout de suite après qui va se
diriger vers le séminaire saint joseph
pour se reposer ça a été très clair on
se rappelle que le pape il a 85 ans il a
des problèmes de santé donc on veut
vraiment qu'il se repose aujourd'hui et
ça sera son temps personnel vous l'avez
bien sûr vu geneviève il n'y a pas eu de
discours officiel de la part du peuple
ses premières paroles seront réservées à
demain lorsqu'il va visiter la
communauté de masques which is et qui va
rencontrer des survivants d'anciens
pensionnats pour autochtones et c'est
d'ailleurs lors de cette journée là
constatant qu'ils devraient et réitéré
ses excuses au peuple autochtone will
dean est paul merci beaucoup merci au
revoir au plaisir
alors je reviens maintenant à mes
invités à mes invitait mais précieux
collaborateurs que dis-je isabelle
picard alain crevier bon d'abord une
réaction générale ce qu'on vient de voir
à cette cérémonie d'accueil
c'est toujours moi je dis il ya un piège
c'est parce qu'ils aient bien passé mais
je dis dans ces affaires là il ya
toujours un piège d'abord parce qu'il ya
un protocole hsts un chef d'état alors
c'est pas ça parce pointe sommes là et
ensuite c'est pas seulement un religieux
c'est aussi le chef d'une église qui est
probablement la plus colossale de
l'histoire de l'humanité alors on peut
une pause emea se dit en passant le
chemin entre en faire l'apologie de
quelque chose centre est de constater
que arrive ça arrive un homme qui est
déjà à 85 en plus amoché quand même lui
même le reconnaît on lui a dit pas plus
que 15 pas défiler alors on voit
l'ampleur de la chose et arrive le
protocole le protocole s'est chargé de
symboles qui serre la main acquis qui
est assis ou qu'est ce qu'on dit et tout
à coup ligue y est ici pour une cause
qui profond qui est rempli de douleur
est là le piège c'est que tout ça
s'efface dans le protocole où on voit
des grands cardinaux parce que là il ya
des candidats en à la diplomatie de plus
et des personnages de jeux preuve parler
pendant des heures qui sont là ne puis
dire oui mais c'est costaud alors on
pourrait voir tout à coup la cause pour
laquelle tout cela est en place ce
protocole dans un protocole lourd
pompeux et je pense que ce pape
peut-être c'est par sa présence parce
que son choix parce que ces décisions
peut-être qu'il a évité ce piège là ça
m'a vraiment injuste surtout aux
premières au premier pape mais il ya un
véritable piège quand arrivent les
histoires de protocoles surtout dans des
causes comme celle ci isabelle est ce
que vous craignez que effectivement là
l'histoire le drame des pensionnats soit
occulté un pupitre ou récupérer ouais
ben c'est une grande question en fait
mais effectivement je suis assez
d'accord avec alain sur le fait que le
protocole risque d'occulter si les trous
présence et les trop fort cette
rencontre l'ocs se doit d'avoir lieu
entre le pape et les survivants des
pensionnats autochtones parce que c'est
cette rencontre leur qu'on vous et elle
ne peut pas s'inscrire dans un protocole
très rigide c'est clair pour les
premiers peuples maintenant
vu de la sobriété de la simplicité j'ai
vu des éléments de rencontre c'était
très court mais pour moi je pense que
c'est un bon début on verra si le reste
y sera l'important aussi c'est que ce
soit pas vous passerez l'expression mais
un gros show on veut vraiment que ça
reste simple sobre humble
alors à la façon à l'image des premières
nations des premiers peuples parce que
sinon et malheureusement et c'est ce que
je crée c'est que cette rencontre n'ait
pas lieu à la hauteur de ce que les
survivants aimerait avoir parce que même
s'il ne fournit pas d excuses qui vont
plus loin que celles qu'il a faites un
rom ça reste quand même que cette
renconte ce face à face ici est très
très important essentiel l'un pour de
nombreux autochtones croyants oui
absolument la symbolique le fait qu'il
se soit déplacé on le dit souvent il a
85 ans il est pas très en forme le fait
qu'il ait accepté de le faire malgré ça
en sol canadien qui se rendent dans
trois endroits clés et dans leur antre
auteuil kellwood c'est pas simple donc
ça effectivement c'est extrêmement
important déjà là c'est un début mais il
faudra qu'on aille plus loin sinon
pourquoi venir il faut qu'on aille plus
loin absolument excellent homme qui
parle il ya été élu bagis toujours par
dessus un autre
oui je comprends parler on pourra parler
du pack demain on aura l'occasion parce
que là maintenant je voulais me faire
entendre l'entretien que j'ai eu avec la
co commissaires de la commission vérité
réconciliation qui pendant plusieurs
années a enquêté sur le système des
pensionnats parce que les sévices suivi
par les autochtones dans les pensionnats
ont fait l'objet de poursuites de
recours collectif en 2006 les entités
catholique d'un gag de l'église de rome
et d'autres églises ou si on dans
l'appareil depuis le début de l'émission
ont décidé s'asseoir avec les
autochtones le gouvernement fédéral et
ont signé une convention
une convention de règlement pour
dédommager les élèves des 139 pensionnat
du pays c'est un règlement judiciaire le
fédéral des dommages est financièrement
les survivants et par lesquels les
églises devait leur verser de l'argent
on a vu tout à l'heure que l'église
catholique n'a pas tout payer ce qu'elle
avait promis de payer cette convention
prévoyait aussi la mise sur pied de la
commission vérité-réconciliation
commission qui a donc demandé ses
excuses ici en territoire autochtone de
la part du pape elle a demandé il devait
le faire en 2016 elle l'espérait ça n'a
pas été fait alors je vous propose
d'écouter cet entretien que j'ai eus
donc avec mary wilson commissaire de
2009 à 2015 de la commission vérité
réconciliation
mais la moindre somme bonjour bonjour
quelles sont les mots que le pape doit
prononcer
mais pour les mots c'est à lui de les
trouver j'espère qu'ils vont chercher à
l'intérieur pour trouver les mots
vraiment qui peut remonter le monde mais
on a fait référence à l'exemple de
l'irlande parce qu'il l'a les excuses
étaient ouverts dans plusieurs niveaux
la société s'était pas juste les enfants
dans ce cas de l'irlande qui avait subi
des abus variés mais c'était aussi des
excuses offertes à tous les membres les
adhérents de l'église catholique parce
que eux aussi il était choqué et
bouleversé et
deux sur
l'infini de qu'est ce qui s'est passé au
nom de leur église est aussi sollicité
des excuses offertes aux prêtres et aux
membres de
en faire des soeurs et les autres les
membres qui étaient mal à la tête sur le
chemin de l'église catholique parce que
c'est pas tout le monde il y avait des
gens qui avaient d'une manière très
dévoué suivi leur appel à la vocation
d'être r tout ça mais l'action de
certains en lice avaient endommagé aussi
donc c'est complexe et la question
globale donc pour revenir la question à
quoi est-ce qu'on s'attend ce que
l'église comme institution total prenne
de responsabilité du manque de
surveillance du manque de on est et du
manque enfin de complicité à la
continuation finalement parce que
lorsque on a des preuves qui sont déjà
connus comme avoir commis des crimes des
dix on le décrit mme bain juste les
envoya ailleurs pour qu'ils sachent se
répète ça c'est l'église qui a comptable
à 100 mais dans lequel je suis dans le
cas la gestion des systèmes de
pensionnat que l'église dont l'église
était responsable finalement mais est ce
que c'est vraiment l'institution église
catholique qui doit être imputables
compte 1 du fait qu'il y avait plusieurs
entités religieuses à lavey près d'une
cinquantaine qui gérait les églises des
grands comme par comparaison les églises
protestantes eu aussi ils ont des
régions ils ont des organisations à
l'intérieur de leur église c'est la tête
de l'église total qui avait offert des
excuses au nom de tout le monde et c'est
ça qui manque encore et l'autre chose
qui était important dans tout ça qu'il
était d'ailleurs bien exprimé dans
certaines des excuses qu'on a déjà
entendu des autres églises c'est la
question non seulement des
responsabilités de l'institution la
question de surveillance et c'est
l'église qui habitent des contrats
avec le gouvernement fédéral pour gérer
ces écoles là mais l'autre chose c'est
que on a beaucoup entendu parler de
l'abus spirituelle comme comme si les
jeunes qui sont allés là à reese est des
endroits où il n'y avait pas déjà des
croyances spirituelles puis on a entendu
maintes fois que ce n'était pas du tout
le cas il avait le croyant ce rituel
pratiqué tout ça est non seulement il on
aura dit que ça c'est que du diable
c'était de l'enfer c'était payant on n'a
même pas se les voir pour que ça soit
plus possible de tenir sa donc l'église
était très impliqué dans sa imposer sa
manière d'avoir des relations avec la et
reçut une clientèle enfin le grand dieu
non qu'on avait utilisé ça aussi ça
prend des excuses et on a parlé de ça
donne un rapport aussi toute cette
question de moralité ce sens à l'ironie
d'ailleurs c'est une institution qui
basé sur une question de hauteur noir et
otages spirituel c'était un abus de soi
même aussi dans ce sens là donc c'est
pour ça qu'on parle de plusieurs niveaux
des excuses tout ça c'est mérité tout ça
je pense serait non seulement pour les
autochtones mais pour les adhérents non
autochtone qui qui sont encore liés
l'église catholique tout ça ça pourrait
leur remettre un peu de confiance aux
obus de cars 2 qu'est ce que c'est
l'église finalement oui maintenant vous
attendiez aussi il y avait de l'argent
que l'aîné s'était engagé je pensais aux
25 millions qu'un guide catholiques
s'étaient engagés à ramasser là encore
il ya des manquements la somme jamais
été recueillis
mais ça c'est vrai et je pense que ça
devient de plus en plus compliqué mais
je pense que c'est ce qui est très
important c'est que cette question
d'argent c'était calculé dans le
contexte de donka portée devant le grand
cube hymne à la cour suprême et c'est un
jugement de la cour suprême qui avait
des obligations y compris la création
d'une commission vérité réconciliation
mais avait aussi des obligations
financières et pour moi c'est toujours
la question qui d'autre pourrait passer
devant la cour au canada appuie un
moment donné on leur dit bercé première
se sert que vous payez le le montant
indiqué par la cour je pense que ça
c'est vraiment quelque chose à se poser
la question est ce que c'est vraiment la
justice
égale pour tout le monde et est ce que
les institutions se protègent encore et
pourquoi est-ce que ça revient au sommet
d'un haut fonctionnaire de payer le
grand travail qui reste encore à
chercher alors bien aimé les enfants
perdus et tout ça tout ça ça prend de
l'argent s'appelant de l'arctique nos
logis qui est très cher aussi et
s'apprend et ça oblige aussi je pense la
participation et
le bien être 2 2 car francs et pure de
la parole d'église sinon ça mettait en
question toute la validité de l'église
elle même mais au delà au delà de ce que
l'église catholique peut faire va faire
ou pas
le drame des pensionnats se décline à
tous les niveaux toute la société est
interpellé dans ce qui se passe dans ce
discours dans cette réflexion qu'on a
ensemble en ce moment parce que les
pensionnats ont coûté cher aux
autochtones en termes d'éducation de
violence d'aliénation de santé c'est un
drame qui se perpétue encore aujourd'hui
n'est-ce pas
oui absolument et tous les chiffres ne
l'indiquent mais la question qu'on doit
se poser là où on vit chacun de nous
c'est justement au niveau de la grande
société qu'est ce qui se passe là où on
vit est-ce qu'on a du curriculum dans
nos écoles de sorte qu ça met fin à
l'ignorance qui a qui a permis que ça
continue si longtemps dans notre
histoire cette lacune de possibilités et
de d'éducation et de de
rugby entre autochtones et non
autochtones
est ce que ça existe au québec est ce
que ça existe dans les écoles
francophones du pays est ce que ça
existe dans toutes les provinces et tous
les territoires moi je sais que ça
existe dans certaines régions mais je
sais que et c'est pas égal à travers le
plus et tant que c'est pas en place on
russe de perpétuer l'ignorance qui
nourrit
cette division sociale et je pense que
là où il ya eu de gros travail de fait
on voie du progrès donc il faut
s'inspirer les uns des autres et
continue ne pas lâcher savoir prendre du
temps et ça va prendre des ressources et
ça va prend la participation des
dépenses des autochtones dont les même
sens deux décisions que les non
autochtones en conclusion madame watson
est ce que ces excuses papale en
territoire autochtone vont avoir l'effet
espéré s comptait même si elle arrive
très tard
mais comme je disais j'espère que ça va
parce que c'est pas juste en territoire
autochtone saab est aussi un des deux
sites de pèlerinage qui sont très
renommé depuis très longtemps par les
catholiques autochtones et non
autochtones
j'espère que ça va être aussi un message
qui aide les la population non
autochtone à mieux comprendre la
situation et elle se poser la question
qu'est ce que nous on peut faire pour
contribuer à la la suite et à un avenir
qui amène le plus égale et donc ça va ça
ou va offrir un soulagement pour
quelques-uns ce que ça ça risque d'orage
et d'autre mais j'espère que ça va
vraiment inspiré de l'action continue et
que ça va accueillir de nouveaux
communauté de collaboration et que ça
peut être
la nourriture qu'il faut pour pour une
société plus respectueuse et avec un
plus d'égalité à travers la grille
l'agrandît vide la grande division qui
existe encore un peu on se le souhaite
mais personne merci beaucoup au revoir
merci au revoir
alors isabelle alain je vous demandais
des commentaires madame oleson d'enfants
nous interpelle tous ces c on ne vient
qu on ne fait que commencer à travailler
sur ce drame mais la façon dont il se
décline partout mais nous sommes
vraiment tous interpellés là-dedans
isabelle ben oui c'est sûr c'est sûr
comme premières nations comme comme
canadiens comme gouvernement commente
clergé je pense que cette histoire là ne
s'est pas vécu en vase clos ce n'est pas
la faute de leurs ou de l'autre il ya
des responsabilités évidemment au niveau
du gouvernement fédéral il ya des
responsabilités au niveau de l'église
qui sont partagés et vous savez pour les
survivants se sont pas des journées
facile et qui s'annonce devant eux en ce
sens qu'ils doivent revivre tout ça
c'est partout dans les médias ont
évidemment tout le monde le sait que le
pape est ici donc évidemment un
survivant qui a subi des agressions
qu'elles soient sexuelles physiques que
psychologiques ou autre n'a pas le choix
que d'être à l'intérieur de lui et de se
remémorer tout ça et de revivre ça alors
on doit être patient on doit avoir
beaucoup de support aussi je pense
j'espère qu'il ya du sport qui est prévu
pour les survivants un peu partout quand
le pape va être présent et voilà oui
parce que ce sera bouleversant pour eux
de se ramener dans cette souffrance en
fait puis oui il ya un an je pense que
les premières nations ont prévu dans
certains cas de la psychologie il ya des
survivants qui se déplace en autobus
avec des psychologues à bord pour les
aider sinon des proches a eu très très
pour les soutenir à leyde mais
aujourd'hui le défi dont on parle qu'on
a tous à relever c'est d'abord et avant
tout celui d'église isabelle faisait
allusion aux agressions sexuelles le
pape dans ses excuses à rome ou encore
monseigneur poisson quand il parlait des
abus commis par des membres du clergé le
mot abus sexuels ne sort pas dans le cas
de ce qui s'est passé mais pensionnats
pour autochtones mais c'est aussi un
moyen de diversion intéressés c'est un
peu dommage parce que je pense que le
premier drame il y d'ordre politique
comme tout le monde le sait maintenant
et on devrait s'en rappeler ce à dire
que c'est un drame politique d'avoir
voulu assassiner une culture et on a
pris tous les moyens qu'on pouvait sauf
le meurtre et ensuite on a demandé à des
églises d'appliquer le mad et ç'a donné
les résultats qu'on connaît
j'écoutais mary wilson à première fois
j'ai par la marine wilson c'était en
2008 à winnipeg et commencer à commencer
la commission commence un long travail
et
en 2015 ils ont remis leur rapport dans
lequel on m'a dit au pape de s'excuser
en moins de renard ce cap délicat mais
ensuite on dit en 2022 le pape arrive
ici je sais que mary wilson a écouté
personnellement monsieur plus de
chiffres exacts de 5000 ou 6000
témoignage
elle est la personne la commune mène là
elle a écouté 5 ou 6000 témoignages et
je la vois la danse qu'elle vous dit
avec une sérénité qui est troublant
c'est très inspirant de voir des gens
qui sont capables de voir clair sans
perdre le nord avec une histoire comme
celle-là je pense que beaucoup de gens
qui pourraient s'inspirer de ça alors on
va continuer en pensez on va poursuivre
là dessus sur les pensionnats mais je
vous propose d'abord de faire une
entrevue avec une entrevue avec le
ministre responsable aujourd'hui des
relations entre les autochtones et la
couronne je vous rappelle que le système
des pensionnats il ya quelques 150 mille
enfants autochtones inuits et métis qui
sont passés par là ça a été mis sur pied
par le tout premier gouvernement fédéral
celui de john et mcdonough le tout
premier premier ministre du canada les
premiers prend pas cela ouvre en
1883 ils ont duré très longtemps cent
ans alors j'en parle donc avec moi que
le monsieur mais le bonjour merci d'être
avec nous aujourd'hui en ce jour très
très très important pour la
réconciliation
le gouvernement fédéral a sa part de
responsabilité dans le système des
pensionnats ils ont été pensés voulue
par le gouvernement fédéral de l'époque
mais quelle est la responsabilité de
l'église catholique dans les mauvais
traitements infligés aux pensionnaires
bonjour je viens vers vous l'avez
souligné c'est une responsabilité
partagée évidemment ce processus
d'assimilation qui a été qui a été menée
par par le canada et les églises
religieuse dont pour 60% des pensionnats
l'église catholique a sa part de
responsabilité n'était pas complète sans
l'implication de la religion évidemment
les prêtres individuelle même système
d'articulation qui arraché aux cultures
autochtones nous avait dit vie du
autochtone aux enfants très jeunes
jusqu'à trois ans leur langue leur
culture leurs liens familiaux les plus
sacrés du traumatisme qui perdure
aujourd'hui vous vous le voyez dans tous
les témoignages oui mais c'était
l'église alors donc le gouvernement
fédéral lui avait conçu ces sept ans est
cette politique d'assimilation mais
c'était l'église qu'il appliquait
pratico pratique dans la vie de tous les
jours oui effectivement des
enseignements de nature religieuse d'un
plan scolaire de nature religieuse pour
enlever pour arracher la culture
autochtone cour considère et
rétrograde du sauvage des mots très très
très blessants pour convertir
pour propos pour enlever ces traditions
très importante pour ces familles leurs
cultures anciennes pour l'heure
la transformer nos petits-enfants blanc
avec la culture européenne ce à cause
des séquelles de traumatismes qui se
transmettent et qui se sentent
aujourd'hui de génération en génération
peu importe silence les enfants
aujourd'hui ont fréquenté l'école où les
pensionnats toi alors le premier
ministre trudeau a demandé en mai 2010
est au pape de s'excuser de venir
s'excuser pour répondre à la demande de
la commission vérité réconciliation
est ce que le gouvernement est ce que
les mots choisis par le pape à rome
répondre complètement aux attentes du
gouvernement canadien
balles et les excuses qui ont été
présentés dans des sciences privé plus
tard plus tôt dans l'année
évidemment ne répondent pas ce qui était
demandé noir sur blanc par l'apel 58 de
la commission vérité-réconciliation
l'expectative c'était que le pape
présente lui-même ses excuses de façon
compréhensif pour l'approché systémique
de l'église catholique sur le sol
canadien devant plusieurs témoins dont
principalement des survivants et leurs
familles alors aujourd'hui c'est un
moment fébrile et des émotions à fleur
de peau il ya plusieurs perspectives qui
se tissent
plusieurs survivants qui veulent savoir
d'autres qui trouvent que ce moment est
un moment très profonde réconciliation
pour pouvoir guérir et passer à la
prochaine étape alors on verra et ce
n'est pas moi qui jugera du fond de la
chose ce sera évidemment les communautés
autochtones et principalement les
survivants et leurs familles ouais est
ce que vous attendez est-ce qu'il aille
encore plus loin demain qu'il ne l'a
fait à rome parce que bon la commission
vous mentionniez l'appel de la
commission vérité-réconciliation
c'étaient des excuses pour les mauvais
traitements spirituel culturel
émotionnels physiques et sexuelles dans
les pensionnats
absolument puis ce que là ce que l'appel
demande spécifiquement ce sont des
excuses qui sont dans la même lignée que
les excuses présentées aux familles
irlandaises qui ont subi c'était
peut-être un mauvais parallèle mais
similaires dans la forme d'assimilation
et les abus les les séquelles qui se
sentent aujourd'hui mais avec la
spécificité autochtone de cet
enseignement de nature chrétienne qui a
été forcée et tout le traumatisme
stricken causer avec
avec les liens familiaux qui était très
profond dans les communautés autochtones
et qui sont en train de se faire rebâtir
aujourd'hui alors les gens évidemment ça
tombe à bien plus monsieur mail en 2006
les représentants de l'église avait
promis 25 millions de dollars pour
dédommager survivants elle n'en a trouvé
que 4 millions je sais que vous étiez
surpris d'apprendre que le gouvernement
fédéral avait renoncé à réclamer sa à
l'église est ce que vous personnellement
vous allez relancer la poursuite
judiciaire pour que l'église fait ce
qu'elle avait promis de payer
ce qu'on sait de cet engagement c'est
que du côté légal ya plus rien à faire
don de ce côté là difficile de de
relancer avec une perspective de succès
est grossier de
cet arrangement le canada et les églises
et les institutions catholiques si que
c'est un échec moral me quasi totale
une responsabilité on sait que dans les
années dans les appuis financiers que le
gouvernement canadien a porté depuis ce
temps là ça commence à monter dans les
milliards et donc un 25 30 millions
c'est bien peu mais on s'attend à cet
argent là pour pour pour l'importance de
la chose pour l'avoir fait parce que
c'était un engagement mais je pense
qu'il y aura un moment réfléchir à ce
qu'ils l'église catholique tout comme
l'église anglicane la fête peut faire
est bien plus dense est dans ce
processus de guérison est ce que le 30
millions justement débloquer annoncé par
les évêques en septembre dernier tourner
dans un fonds de réconciliation est ce
que ça répond à ce cas à quoi on peut
s'attendre de la part de l'église
ce que je peux dire c'est qu'on s'attend
cette somme là évidemment qu'il faut que
les gens fassent l'effort
mais il ya bien plus que l'argent qui
compte il ya des gens qui sont encore
blessés
il ya beaucoup de tragédies dans les
communautés autochtones qui sont le
résultat direct des pensionnats
autochtones donc il ya un rôle bien aura
toujours un rôle pour l'église
catholique dans ce processus qui qui ne
se terminera pas de m le gouvernement
fédéral a entrepris de répondre aux 94
demande de la commission vérité et
réconciliation dans tous les domaines
c'est l'éducation la médecine la santé
la violence faite aux femmes c'est c'est
infini tous les domaines de la société
sont sont affectés la commission de
demander à ce que les actions dans
chacun ces domaines là est ce que vous
diriez vous en tant que représentant du
fédéral qui reste encore beaucoup de
travail à faire
tout le monde puis ça se limite c'est un
effort de société yves démaria
je dirais 70 ans ou plus qui relève
directement de l'implication du
gouvernement fédéral mais il y en a bien
d'autres qui relève de la société civile
en grec les provinces les territoires
les médias aussi dont l'importante de
prime abord c'est éduquer comme société
de ce que si l'appel à l'action
contiennent comme que comme appel mais
aussi passer à l'action oc puis une
question d'ignorance qui perdure
toujours dans la société canadienne
aussi après l'apprentissage
à une responsabilité d'actions qui
incombe à tous évidemment principalement
le gouvernement du canada non mais le
représentant de ce gouvernement
ministres responsables des relations
couronne autochtone merci beaucoup
d'avoir écrit aujourd'hui au revoir leur
fille isabelle je vous interpelle tout
de suite justement 94 responsable
appelle l'action c'est par la commission
vérité-réconciliation 70 ce qui relève
du gouvernement fédéral est ce que il
s'acquitte bien de chaque tâche à cet
égard vous parlez du gouvernement
fédéral oui
oui et non évidemment on peut toujours
en faire plus je pense que là où le
gouvernement fédéral pourrait faire
davantage c'est au niveau des
investissements au niveau à des langues
et des cultures autochtones vous savez
une des conséquences d'importantes des
pensionnats pour autochtones ça a été
justement l'éradication de plusieurs
langues à travers le pays de plusieurs
cultures et de tout ce qui fait partie
de la culture dont la spiritualité et là
le gouvernement fédéral peut venir
investir davantage pour conserver ce qui
reste et transmettent également ce qui
reste les aînés se font de plus en plus
ceux qui possèdent à ces éléments de
l'angle les derniers locuteurs se font
de plus en plus âgés même chose pour ce
qui est de la culture
l'accès au territoire aussi évidemment
tout ça c'est un briquet ensemble et
leur là dessus je pense que le
gouvernement fédéral pourrait en faire
davantage vous allez le ministre a parlé
ou s'ils lui d'une faillite morale de
l'église un on venait de parler des
sommes que l'église avait promise et qui
n'ont pas été payés les villes istres
était assez loin à ce fort j'ai trouvé
une faillite morale il ya je pense qu'il
est juste aussi parce que produire une
chose comme celle là est absolument
inouïe et puis souvenez vous en dis
souvent à il faut pas juger le passé
avec les yeux d'aujourd'hui oui oui mais
une posture qu'on peut toujours s'en
sortir comme ça il ya des choses qui est
inacceptable il s'entend pile elles le
sont encore aujourd'hui et l'autorité de
l'église est encore peut-être plus
souveraine il ya certains qu'elle ne
l'est aujourd'hui dans ce pays notamment
comme le canada où on a pris beaucoup de
distance par rapport à l'église à la
toux d'un coup on voit bien quel était
le rôle et quelle était la puissance
d'une institution comme celle-là je
trouve je souris un tout petit peu parce
que je vois que dans le nouveau faut
qu'on essaie de concocter à la
conférence des évêques beaucoup de bonne
volonté j'ai aucun doute mais il ya un
parti où on dit ça pourrait servir à la
re découverte de la spiritualité des
premiers peuples et m c'est précisément
parce qu'on a essayé d'éliminer la
langue la culture et la spiritualité
alors qu'aujourd'hui on scie
avant tout simplement le monopole de
cette manière de voir qui était celui de
l'église catholique et vous avez
peut-être là une piste qui est toute
petite tenue de rien du tout mais qui
m'apparaît comme vraiment significatif
allons maintenant parler à quelqu'un qui
fait partie de ceux des milliers de
personnes qui vont se déplacer pour
aller entendre le pape certains vont
faire en groupe le déplacement comme
julie au wat qui quitte demain la
réserve de pikogan en abitibi en autobus
avec une quarantaine d'autres
autochtones pour aller voir le pape elle
à québec coué madame en watts
oui bonjour alors
on était une trentaine oui et puis vous
avez besoin les gens avec qui vous
partez vous même avez besoin d'entendre
de voir le pape s'excuser
la plupart des gens lui demandent des
excuses oui je demande aussi des excuses
macadam est-ce que ça vienne parce que
je sais pas trop comment que ça va ça va
m'affecter
dans ce sens que oui les excuses sur
l'eau mais j'oublie pour j'oublie poste
qui est ce qui est arrivé
est ce que est ce que le fait qu'il
vienne au canada qu'ils soient présents
devant vous
c'est plus important encore plus
significatif
d'une certaine manière oui parce que
c'est l'église qui nous qui nous a fait
vivre ces traumatismes là le fait que
c'est ce soit reconnu que les personnes
qui ont vécu dans les pensionnats soient
reconnus comme étant des personnes qui
ont vécu des traumatismes
moi même j'ai végétaux pour un scanner
pendant deux ans je suis parti j'avais
six ans parti pour aller au pensionnat
et puis je sors cela j'avais 8 ans 9 ans
à peu près quand je suis parti du
pensionnat mais pendant ces deux années
là j'ai vécu des traumatismes
d'épouvantables
la première journée au pensionnat la
religieuse me demande qu'est ce que je
veux faire plus tard
avec qui j'ai eu moi même du haut de mes
6 ans je dis que je veux l'être james
mais c'est dans ma tête à moi je voulais
pas être religieuse je voulais me
protéger
puis pendant tous ces deux années là gt
gt sous la protection de cette
religieuse
et
gl me protéger moi j'ai pas eu de l'abus
physique j'ai pas été battu je parie que
d'agression sexuelle mais j'en ai vu
passer j'ai vu des enfants se faire
battre
ces images le sont toujours là dans ma
tête je t'en parle quand j'entends des
bruits ou est ce que c'est que ce faible
j'en ai mal au coeur alors oui j'ai
envie oui c'est encore le c6 traumatisme
c'est ça ce sont vraiment des
traumatismes qui restent longtemps gravé
qui peuvent être réveillés à l'occasion
de deux d'un événement comme ça ne
visait pas pâle c'est pour ça que je
pense qu il ya un psychologue qui vous
accompagnent dans ce périple vers québec
oui il est un psychologue qui qui nous
accompagnent parce qu éventuellement
certaines personnes vont vivre vont
revivre ce qu'ils ont vécu au pensionnat
je suis certain que moi aussi je veux
avoir des images des flashbacks durant
ses voyages parce que comme je dis on
est à peu près une trentaine qui vient
c'est tout des gens que je connais je
peux leur histoire
ça va être des bouts savoie et émouvoir
mais en même temps moi j'y vais pas pour
aller voir le pape support vraiment pour
dire waouh je veux voir le pape moi
c'est par solidarité que j'y vais parce
que je suis allé au pensionnat avec tous
les autres qui sont kim hwan qui vont
nous accompagner pour aller là-bas c'est
pour être solidaire avec avec ligne et
pourquoi le pape voit vous voit
oui le paba nous voir quand l'homme
quand on devrait participer à la messe
le
jus de jeudi à la basilique sainte anne
mais encore là non seulement 400 places
400 places pour les survivants puis la
basilique contient 1400 ou 1600 place
une juste 400 places prises et pour les
curieux dans notre groupe de seulement
dix personnes qui vont pouvoir assister
à un avc
présenté par le pape alors il s'est
encore d'accord c'est encore l'église
qui est des 6 2 était pas là c'est
toujours une mini miss et toujours pas
loin
alors tout ça tout ça vous déçoit si je
comprends bien
oui je suis déçu pied beaucoup de gens
qui sont déçus parce que on s'en va voir
le peuple on est encore restreint
d'accord encore un petit groupe qui vont
voir le pape oui on me voit de loin ce
je suis le petit groupe de 10 personnes
de pikogan qui vont mois yum
c'est ce que je boucle ce que je voulais
dire tout à l'heure c'est que en vous
déplaçant comme vous disiez vous vous
faites par solidarité pas parce que vous
avez besoin de le voir mais par
solidarité mais en y allant comme ça on
si grand nombre le pape va pas mesuré va
sentir dans dans sa chair si je puis
dire
l'ampleur du désastre des pensionnats
plusieurs annonces plus ce sera le
message qui va recevoir
j'espère j'espère qu'il va comprendre
puis aussi j'espère que les ce que moi
ce que je demande au pape ce qui est des
actions concrètes qu'ils soient posées
c'est bien beau d excuse mais il faut
voir des gestes cop etc soit posée
qu'est ce que je le que les personnes
qui ont commis les actes de ces crimes
là soit face à face à la justice
comme adam morrison le disais tout à
l'heure ces points en déplaçant les
curés d'une communauté à l'autre que ça
va régler des choses
c'est en poursuivant ces gens-là
d'injustice que
juste matin qui va avoir une certaine
réparation
je demande aussi crié comme madame ours
en disaient qu'il y ait des choses
day2 psychologique ou les personnes qui
ont vécu ces traumatismes qui est d un
psycho logique parce que c'est pas
facile encore de de vivre avec ça dans
ce sens que on a encore des des
flashbacks on a encore des des images
qui nous reviennent en tête quand on on
assiste des fois des rencontres ou
est-ce que
des choses qu'on assiste ses principaux
ainsi complaisant avec les flashback
pour les images nous reviennent oui je
veux aller c'est un exemple dans le
temps mais je cachais du pensionnat
c'est sûr on n'avait pas le droit pas de
parler notre langue
et notre langue aussi été bafoués on est
et
on n'avait pas le droit de parler notre
langue donc si on parlait de notre
l'homme ont des enfants que sont peintes
battre parce qu'il parlait leur langue
déclare aussi fait partie de ces choses
qu'on a perdu perdu dans ce sens qu il
ya des choses encore à travailler
section il faudrait que d
une compensation de monétaire pour qu'on
puisse travailler sous la langue ouais
judy mowatt merci beaucoup pour votre
témoignage est bon bon séjour à québec
pourra jouer la dalle bellefleur aussi
est une survivante de pensionnat elle
vit à natashquan mais sera à québec pour
la visite du pat quinn alain bellefleur
bonjour vous êtes resté je crois une
fervente catholique même si vous avez
subi le système des pensionnats pourquoi
n'avez-vous pas perdu la foi ou
confiance en l'église
oui parce que moi j'ai toujours vécu
raid dans les grands parrains par
tradition on a toujours suivi notre
pastorale
tout en garde à nous pas là d'un beau
pays
ce que les missionnaires ou enseigner no
parano grand parade c'est ce que j'ai
toujours conservé
comme j'avais été enseignée par
paru mais que ma part à l'écart je suis
arrivé au passionnant ça à toujours
continuer c'est que moi ma foi j'ai
toujours conservé la 20 mots pour me
tradition oui mais vous avez été arraché
à une tradition si la traduction
autochtone nous avait été arrachée à
votre famille vos parents vous avez été
déracinés tout ça
oui c'est sûr ça a été très dur aussi
j'en conviens c'était un vrai
déracinement
mais je me suis toujours
continuer à
apprendre avec eux que ce qui m'a montré
impressionnant c'est que
je me disais combiner les deux ensemble
ça va être
très
précis tournoi pour écouler les deux
traditions de déblais ni des miennes
j'ai toujours conservé c'est toujours
fonctionné la date au coq au cours des
neuf années que quand vous avez été au
pensionnat ce que vous avez été
maltraité vous-même ou témoins de
mauvais traitements à d'autres
partenaires
le non-match
à
il suffit par les autres parce que
j'étais petit j'étais un peu plus âgé je
sais que
je sors pendant ce mois j'avais
j'avais un visa pour la neige pourraient
prôner une
exprimé comme faux parce que la langue
autour de 2 à 3 ans j'ai pu
mais décembre comme je pouvais c'est que
moi j'ai toujours
me suis toujours
défendu le mieux que je pouvais
mais pouvait désormais les plus jeunes
oui j'ai du d
day les attouchements du côté des jeunes
il est pour moi aussi mais j'ai été
capable
d'aimer les femmes en évitant de ceux
qui voulaient me maltraiter cette
rigueur je pouvais
vivre
c'est un superbe roulé y est
alors comme vous semblez comme vous
semblez avoir vous être réconciliés en
partie avec cette maltraitance se passer
qu'est ce que les excuses du pape vont
vous apporter de plus
les excuses du pub vont m'apporter un
peu plus
les considérations qui a envers nous et
la considération
kg à reconnaître
notre peuple
bien
que j'admire son humilité de vouloir
nous excuser à vers notre nation
il y a
la place des hommes
moi je l'aimé beaucoup de son courage de
vouloir nous deux femmes il nous
considérer comme comme
je vous remercie beaucoup pour votre
témoignage à delle belfort merci
beaucoup et bon mon voyage vers québec
au revoir
merci
isabelle picard une réaction à deux
témoignages donc de survivants qui lui
n'a pas vraiment besoin de voir le pape
et l'autre est très content d'aller voir
ça représente bien des autochtones n'est
ce pas oui effectivement c'est un peu
les deux écoles de pensée mais il ya
toute cette au delà de ça y est tout
seul d'arrêter la con con qu'on ressent
de la part de ces femmes là et je veux
même revenir sur roméo saganash qu'on a
entendu aussi plutôt est ce que je
retiens de ces trois survivants le sait
cette espèce de
de fait inévitable de devoir devenir
adulte trop tôt à l'âge de 6 ans à l'âge
de 7 ans de devoir déjà défendre les uns
ou les autres de devoir dire qu'on vous
devenir religieuse parce que on sait
qu'on va se mettre la religieuse de son
bord puis que le séjour va être plus
simple de devoir de se détacher aussi
parce qu'on est en train de comprendre
ce que c'est que le pensionnat dans
lequel on est à l'âge de 7 ans c'est
beaucoup trop tôt et ça je l'entend
beaucoup de la part de plusieurs
survivants
et
ça c'est l'essence même je pense de la
détresse qui ont été vécues par
plusieurs
plusieurs survivants et c'est très lourd
et c'est très difficile d'entendre ça de
la part de ces personnes là et je suis
contente qu'elle se rende sur place ces
deux dames là pour être avec tout le
monde et pouvoir partager ça parce que
vous savez c'est beaucoup plus facile de
traverser les épreuves à plusieurs
évidemment pendant trop longtemps les
autochtones ont vécu ça chez eux dans
leur garde-robe en fait et en parler à
personne même pas à leurs familles donc
je pense que c'est une étape qui est
nécessaire est tant mieux si ça leur
fait du pied alors je vous propose
maintenant merci isabelle je propose
maintenant d'écouter un autre témoignage
celui que j'ai recueillis cette semaine
avec la fille d'une survivante de
pensionnat vous allez voir c'est
intergénérationnel où si elle est
maintenant sénatrice elle a été
commissaire à l'enquêté nationale sur
les femmes et les filles autochtones
disparues et assassinées
michèle audette écoutons là michèle
audette bonjour
cauet ago
alors votre maire a passé son enfance
dans un de ces pensionnats maudit
qu'attend-elle comme excuse de la part
du pape
mais j'ai compris que ne voulait pas du
tout venir à s'étendre de beaupré
lorsqu'elle avait reçu l'appel de notre
communauté les gens qui organisent et
bien sûr helmand expliqué que ça fait
plus de souffrance que de délivrance
d'avoir cette expérience est que ce
n'est pas son passage qui vont lui
remettre ce qu'elle a perdu mais plutôt
à et la firme puisse se sen t bien de
manger chez nous c'est comme ça bon
est-ce qu'elle va suivre tout de même
cette visite à la télévision peut-être
nous la connaissons
elle va mélange de prises demain il va
verser des larmes elle va peut-être voir
des gens qu'il connaît où elle va
entendre des choses qu'elle connaissait
donc à quelque part on à ma mère ma
belle mabileau gento qui vont le vivre
de façon très intime mais en même temps
nous les enfants on n'est ce pas moi je
l'espère que vos pouvoir crier ce qu'il
a envie de crier ou vivre ce qu'il a
envie de vivre cette journée là où
pendant dix semaines dans la semaine au
pardon et après ça se dire ben moi je
suis vivante picasso mais je continue et
pour vous une salle odette fille de
cette survivante d'un pensionnat mais
aussi militante autochtone de longue
date vous représenter la communauté
d'une certaine façon qu'est ce que ces
excuses que le pape s'en vient faire
représente pour vous je ne sais pas j
j'essaie d'être tout de suite tout ça
mais ça bien brasser des choses donc je
joue je regardais jouer écouter
parce que vous attendez un style est ce
que vous espérez même qu'il aille plus
loin qu'il ne l'a fait rome ou si le
fait que se dépouille ah oui je vous
écoute ah oui
les excuses sont importantes pour
beaucoup de gens pour d'autres c'est
c'est ça signifie rien je me situe dans
le respect mais je me connais la tête de
caribous août à dire je vais espérer
qu'on ait beaucoup plus de temps pour
accéder aux archives
pouvoir comprendre ses archives on sait
qu'il ya quelqu'un qui manitoba qui est
revenue et c'était trop court ça pour
moi ça va être dans comment je vais
honorer comme pape et représentant d'une
grande communauté religieuse les excuses
au quotidien à partir de mon passage ici
au canada ces archives dont vous parlez
sont des archers qui devrait éclairer ce
qui s'est passé dans les pensionnats et
commencer petit morts ont été inhumés
c'est ça l'important pour vous des
archives quand on parle d'art chez vous
et qu'elle soit d'un certaines
communautés religieuses à travers le
canada ou à rome de ne pas empêcher ou
de ralentir ou de prétendre que mais
d'ouvrir
d'ouvrir cet espace parce que la vérité
les poussiéreuse et les lads alors il
mérite de dépoussiérer pour que beaucoup
de jeunes dans ma mère et bien d'autres
femmes et hommes de cette génération là
puissent enfin vivre lieu de survivre
alors le drame des pensionnats on sait a
été inter générationnelle encore de
l'impact aujourd'hui sur les plus jeunes
générations
vous vous en avez subi des répercussions
personnelles en tant que fille de l'ex
pensionnaire
mais collectivement ou de façon
individuelle
de pas pouvoir parler ma langue et nous
couronnement de la comprendre mais de
pouvoir l'honorer à chaque jour comme ma
mère et bien d'autres gens qui ont été
capables de garder ça c'est une
souffrance d'une rage ou ben voyons donc
ça fait partie de mon identité
culturelle puis je peux même pas la
faire vibrer correctement ça ça fait mal
et après ça de 2 à 51 ans que j'avais 50
ans il ya quelques jours lorsque j'ai
envoyé mon formulaire pour la
compensation des écoles de jour de
revivre toutes ces agressions ou cette
violence a fait mais faut le faire pour
le faire mais est ce que j'aurai des
preuves comme bien d'autres gens auront
ils assez de preuves je suis sûr que non
mais je leur ai dit dans mon témoignage
par écrit peut-être qu'on satisfait pour
vos preuves mais je peux vous dire que
notre vivant nous on les vit au
quotidien ces violences de l'agnel vous
parler de ces écoles de jour vous avez
été dont vous naissez pas pensionnaires
à longueur d'année comme l'était votre
mère mais vous avez quand même fréquenté
les pensionnats en externe si je peux
dire ou es pire des gens qui l'ont vécu
beaucoup plus longtemps que moi des gens
que je connais aujourd'hui que je côtoie
encore et je les vois forte mais on y
fragile hadopi j'ai beaucoup
d'admiration le bruit ouais parmi les
nombreux impacts négatifs des
pensionnats il y à la violence en
particulier contre les femmes
autochtones
plus fréquentes que dans la population
générale et vous vous avez été comme ça
justement de cette enquête nationale sur
les femmes et filles autochtones
disparues ou assassinées quels sont les
lier à faire entre cette violence et les
pensionnats
ils sont on nous a ordonné de trouver
les racines ou les causes systémiques et
la première qu'on va
rencontrer à chaque
audience qu'elles soient publiques
privées et crée tout déclarations c'est
des femmes et des hommes qui ont été
affectés par les pensionnats donc la
violence coloniale la racine dans les
pensionnats ils ont
été nommés à chaque place pique quand
j'entends les gens me dire bloquer leur
donner un don c'est du passé après une
enquête nationale de voir une femme qui
a perdu beaucoup de monde dans sa
famille ou sa fille où sa soeur elles
sont toutes malheureusement comme des
petites perles interreliés à une
expérience ou un véhicule est heureuse
dans un pensionnat
alors la danse est dans cette
perspective dans toute cette souffrance
qu'est ce que vous espérez que la visite
du pape va apporter
ce que j'espère de façon
personnelle de quelqu'un qui habiterait
kalou et tout est à montréal ou chez
nous un maillot
d'accepter que pour beaucoup d'entre
nous
c'est nécessaire parce que les familles
les individus l'ont demandé pendant la
commission vérité-réconciliation faut
accepter ça j'espère aussi que suisse et
qui croit pas tout à ça bennoo qui
marche on dans un chemin où on croit
qu'on doit participer à une guérison et
deezer et collective pour quand même d
accompagner quand même pensé tout de
suite ceux qui croient pas ça mais qui
vit dans la souffrance ou qui vivent
dans le mall grives michèle audette on
espère en tout cas que tout ça nous
aidera tous faire le chemin de la
réconciliation merci beaucoup
témoin qui gros merci au revoir
quoi
je vous propose maintenant d'entendre la
très brève réaction de georges arcand
juniors c'est le grand chef de la
confédération des six premières nations
qui vient de rencontrer le pape françois
l'aéroport dentoni couteau le
jde et leurs zones à partir du 10
novembre inexpérience pour me to be
depuis paris 10 aix comme d'hab
alors voilà des attentes on l'entend on
vienne entendre à travers des
témoignages vraiment intéressant
poignant
à les picards picard pourquoi je pensais
alain picard non sa collègue à nous qui
d'ailleurs
aller creuser pardon
mais lisa belliato
mis en scène à la guitare qui était
pas loin de là je vous fait réagir tout
simplement est ce qu'est ce qu'on vient
d'entendre d'abord aux témoignages et
michèle audette ben c'est sur écoute ici
c'est je pense que l'on ne saisit mal
mais on vous avait parlé à
saganash est plutôt bahia où des
poussières et a parlé à sa fille maïté
m'étais jamais mis les pieds dans un sac
je passais mes mails est ce que je vais
vous dire que çà se multiplier sa part
je ne sais combien est sûr que c'est
capital c'est à dire que cette fille là
qu'ils avaient à peine 30 heures avait
vécu comme héritière de tous les
problèmes ne sont pas pu de la famille
avait elle a vécu ce pleinement jusqu'à
ce que le mandat des quelque chose clic
qu'elles se disent il faut que j'aie ma
vie et elle me dit des choses assez
étonnante mais qui nous dit dans le fond
on l'on parle des survivants on oublie
souvent les enfants des survivants et on
oublie parfois oui exactement ils font
partie de cette communauté qui ont été
affectés directement le jeu parce que
quand j'entends une chaîne odette je me
dis ou quand j'entends saganash ou
d'autres comme ça ou ghislain picard je
me dis il faudrait quand même pas perdre
de vue qu'il ya une action partie mais
un hack survive il ya des gens qui n'ont
jamais mis les pieds là dedans mais qui
vivent qui sont les héritiers de tous
problèmes il est réel parce qu isabelle
picard il nous reste une très très
brèves minutes mais il faut qu'on
comprenne dans le fond à travers tout ça
que c'est profond là ce que s'est passé
cc des communautés entières qui se
déhanche et leurs enfants et les enfants
quand sa rivale un pensionnat leur
coupait les cheveux la longueur des
cheveux longs traditionnel on l'a on les
empêchait on les battait pour ne pas
qu'ils parlent leur langue
absolument on faisait en faisant en
sorte tout ce qu'on pouvait faire en
fait pour qu'ils ne soient plus indien
puisque c'est comme ça qu'on nommait à
l'époque et ç'a eu des conséquences
directes sur les survivants mais on le
dit aussi sur les générations futures
donc ce sont des conséquences qui sont
multi générationnel qui sont
transversales aussi parce que même si on
n'est pas directement un survivant on ne
parle qu'une sale eng où il ya des
éléments culturels qu'on a perdu qu'on a
oublié au niveau de la spiritualité de
la vision du monde c'est la même chose
et le travail à faire il est énorme
alors j'espère que cette visite du pape
vont rendre l'invisible visible oui à
l'est
et puis quand je vais vous dire alain
crevier demain est une grosse journée
c'est la journée des excuses c'est
demain matin que le pape françois vallet
prononcé il va le faire sur le site d'un
ancien pensionnat autochtone 26 vrai et
ça nous donne l'occasion de se poser la
question à savoir mais on dit toujours
des excuses des excuses et mais qu'est
ce que c'est des excuses et est ce que
quand est-ce qu'il arrive le mot magique
pardon et arrive quand ce mot là et si
kiel qui disent à ces choses là est ce
que parce qu'on s'est excusé le pardon
arrive après non et qu'est ce que ça
signifie pour la suite des choses toute
cette idée peut-être qu'il ya des gens
dans les premières nations dans les
premiers peuples qu'ils seront contents
de voir que le pape reconnaît quelque
chose mais qui vont peut-être s'arrêter
là en attendant la suite maintenant
c'est beau parler maintenant voir les
gestes alors je pense que c'est un
moment
énorme convient qu'on vivra de meilleurs
mais il sait des choses qui vont passer
ou casser et très émouvante on le voit
combien il est beaucoup d'émotion non
tout ça on aura j'espère ont l'occasion
de recueillir des témoignages sur place
demain avant pendant après les excuses
mais isabelle quand on parle de gestes
concrets de la part de l'église ou de
juste concrète ou cours au delà de ses
excuses qu'elle serait la priorité si
vous deviez en choisir un seul geste
concret l'accès aux archives pour moi ça
c'est majeur parce que c'est comme ça
qu'on va pouvoir mettre les différentes
pièces du casse-tête ensemble et c'est
dans la vérité qu'on peut commencer une
guérison et pas autrement alors pour moi
on doit donner cet accès complet aux
archives individuelles et générales
alors isabelle picard alain crevier
merci beaucoup on vous retrouve demain
matin pour notre notre deuxième émission
spéciale qui commencera donc à 11h or
delays heure de l'est
c'était donc notre première émission on
prend très à coeur joie sur notre rôle
dans ce dossier cette page sombre moment
de l'histoire de notre pays on a voulu
mettre la table pour comprendre
l'importance des passeurs des
pensionnats le rond des pensionnats les
l'importance des excuses donc que le
pape fera demain on sait sur des images
justement du cortège papal qui est
arrivé à son lieu de résidence où il va
passer le reste de l'âge né à edmonton
avant d'entreprendre cette grosse
journée
essentielle des excuses de mai à demain
rendez vous à tous 11 heures demain
matin
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]